project Veritas has reportedly fired the
entirety of its staff related to news
now I don't know the full details we
don't know exactly what that means there
was a tweet that went out that said SOS
Hannah Giles has fired everybody but
this is completely unsurprising they
betrayed James O'Keefe and it was only a
matter of time before they ran out of
money and were forced to fire everybody
so what we're hearing is that news
operations and these individuals they're
all gone
it's over and so that's the big breaking
story that's happening right now but we
do have a lot to talk about Donald Trump
has responded to the indictment and he
is asking the court for an April 2026
trial date that's right 17 months after
the election
he wants to uh have that trial so we
will see how that plays out I have a
feeling they may remand Trump to custody
everyone keeps saying no they won't do
that that would go too far but I'm sorry
when we said they would indict as
lawyers they said that would go too far
when we said Trump would be indicted
people are like that would go too far no
matter what seems to be happening
everyone keeps saying ah that'll never
happen then it happens oh the antifa
will never kill a guy in the street then
they kill a guy in the street oh Trump's
not going to get indicted then he gets
indicted four times on like 90 plus
counts then the indict his lawyers so
yeah that may be coming and then we have
some really amazing uh cultural news
rich men north of Richmond is expected
to debut at number one across the board
with nearly 100 000 digital sales in a
week it's massive he's crushing
everybody else let me tell you guys when
we hit number one we had something like
20 000 sales so for Oliver Anthony to
have five times that he's going to be
debuting the top of the top and uh oh
the woke press they're really really
angry they're calling him a plant
they're saying that it's a uh it's
nonsensical right-wing populism and that
it's attacking the poor and yeah they
cannot handle when people outside of the
institutions succeed culturally so we're
gonna talk about all these subjects
before we get started you know it head
over to castbrew.com buy our coffee
check out the commercial starring Ian
Crossland we got the cast Brew Coffee
Club join our coffee Club you'll get
three different bags every single month
we got ground we got whole bean we got
light dark medium roast when and we have
K-Cups so we're sponsoring ourselves but
here's the real reason we have Casper
coffee it's not because we want want to
sell you a product not entirely it's
because we are building a coffee shop
which should be hopefully open some
sometime the next couple of months our
projection is around Halloween it may
get delayed a little bit because we have
to do some construction stuff but it's
looking pretty good once we have that up
I want to immediately figure out
franchising and getting anybody who
wants to open their own to open their
own so we can have this decentralized
network of cultural hubs where people
can come together hang out and share
ideas so go to casper.com buy our coffee
if you want to support that endeavor and
also head over to timcast.com click join
us become a member because we're gonna
have a members only uncensored show
coming up for you at about 10 pm where
you as members get to call in submit
questions and talk to us live on the
uncensored show you'll need to be a
member for at least six months or sign
up at the 25 per month level it's a
screening process to keep out weirdos
and far leftists and anybody's trying to
sabotage or anything so we have to do it
you can uh don't forget to smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show right now take that URL
post it wherever you can that really
does help we have been reportedly
throttled people are saying that they're
not getting notified anymore election
season is coming so if the very least
the only thing you can do to help is
just share the video it really does help
joining us tonight to talk about this
and to give us some tremendous insights
we were already talking quite a bit
about what's going on with Trump's legal
Affairs we've got Sean Spicer good to be
with you guys again I'm excited to be
back brand new show coming out Monday
the Sean Spicer show uh right down on
YouTube Sean M Spicer Rumble but if you
go to Sean Spicer show.com you can get
it on any platform we're also going to
be on the first which is great so all
platforms uh Monday and as I said well
before we went on air the great thing is
primaries caucuses conventions debates
the race for 270. I'm gonna break it
down every day what are the rules and
how can we win I think too often the
right doesn't get what it takes to win
we need to know the rules if we're
actually going to win so I'm excited to
be here tonight absolutely plus uh as I
mentioned just before the show we were
already talking about what goes into
these legal challenges the amount of
time energy the hundreds of thousands of
dollars and uh it was starting to get
good I'm like we better hold off because
uh pause you were agreeing to an extent
that we ain't seen nothing yet oh I
think your your analysis was spot on
right this is we we keep thinking and
this is the problem with and part of the
reason I wanted to launch the show and
frankly just to be a little praiseworthy
here you've led the way in this
Independent Media and I've been in a
huge admirer of of frankly the Empire
that you guys have built and you've done
it every single night and I I hope to
have half of the energy that you guys do
every night uh but but that's the point
is that we keep saying and you said this
a minute ago it will never come to this
oh we can you know this is what if we
don't start playing better and by
understanding the rules and how we can
use them to win then we're we're gonna
you might as well give up but earlier
today somebody said Can Trump win I'm
like yes of course Trump can win we keep
falling into the sense of letting the
left change the rules we saw it during
covet over and over again you talked
about it with the legal consequences if
we don't start using the rules for our
on our side to win then we will never
and they get it they understand the
money and the activism that it takes to
change things and then we keep falling
behind the thing the the eight ball and
so this is what's happening you brought
it up legally they we keep saying this
will never happen yes it will it keeps
getting worse it keeps it's getting
worse and then we go okay well it won't
get even more and it gets more worse
we'll jump in all that I want to save it
because the the experiences you had
dealing with Mueller was already
massively enlightening so thanks for
joining us should be real fun we have
Hannah Claire bremelo hanging out hey
I'm hankler I'm a writer for timcast.com
I'm really excited for tonight's
conversation answer too hi everyone Ian
Crossland also very happy to be here I'm
in a race with Clint Russell Liberty
lockpod on Twitter to 100 000 followers
so follow Liberty lockpod and myself
I'll bring it up again near the end of
the show to remind you but I'm happy to
be here good to see you Sean it's really
good to see you man Serge tell me about
it yo I am at surge.com I am wearing my
anti-social Social Club shirt that I got
from conservative ant yesterday uh let's
just jump into it here's the breaking
news right now project Veritas CEO
reportedly fires all of the organization
staff the nonprofit has been plagued by
internal turmoil for the last year
following the termination of founder
James O'Keefe the official project
verdox uh project Veritas X account
that's what it's funny X Twitter account
shared the message SOS Hannah Giles just
fired us all such a weird goings-on an
unnamed Source confirmed timcast the
project Veritas staff has been let go
and further claimed the Chief Financial
Officer for the nonprofit has resigned
the source told timcast donations dried
up there was a massive drop in financial
support and the writing was on the wall
for months Jack besobic the senior
editor at human events also said a
source had confirmed the validity of the
message all of production all the field
Ops all of comms all of legal the source
told Pacific according to an online post
only remaining are office admin HR
person a couple development people and
I.T the organization which has been
known for breaking a number of
significant stories had been plagued by
administrative turmoil this year this is
absolutely amazing to me and predictable
we knew it was only a matter of time the
post-millennial also has additional
information uh breaking exclusive chaos
at project Veritas almost all employees
have been laid off
and they go on to add a little bit more
here
she came to All Hands in April with her
quiz a quote with her fat sidekick Ben
Wetmore and all they did for three days
was talk-ish about James and relitigate
all the terrible things he did to her
and them 10 to 12 years ago I knew right
then her entire agenda was Revenge
on-air Talent Christian uh Hartsock
James lelino were both laid off after
Giles told staff that a restructuring
would be underway Caitlin Erickson Jamie
Phillips Alyssa Dayan were also fired
the terminations were done via Zoom call
with HR with a few of those in the New
York office Giles did not make an
appearance she's a lying sack of ish A
source told the post-millennial no one
respected her anyway here's what I have
to say about all this
if you still worked at project Veritas I
don't know I've I got very little
sympathy for you they came after founder
and leader James O'Keefe they tried to
strip him of everything he built
and there were people who were party to
the knives in the back of James O'Keefe
who signed a letter calling him out so I
just have to say I'm not calling out
anyone individually because I don't know
who but to all the people who stabbed
James in the back and have now lost
their jobs
um schadenfreiter like what this is what
you deserve did you think that this
organization could survive without the
man who built it and was doing the hard
work and making the sacrifices to keep
it up and running these people firmly
believed they were the ones doing it all
and surprise surprise the moment you
betray your leader
all the money's gone they bring in a
shark who then nukes you
okay
yeah it's been a wild year do you guys
remember that coup at project Veritas
the thing that stands out to me the most
is that letter that was signed by like
16 employees they had all these uh you
know they said that James is a tyrant he
does all these terrible things and how
all these examples one was that this
donor felt like you know he hadn't been
friendly to her or something and then
afterwards that dinner was like that's
not what happened that's not it at all
like he was like short with some woman
and then they were like what are you
talking about James was perfectly fine
he stole a woman's sandwich so this this
group of people that said we can do it
without him thought they could also hold
on to the donors who were paying for
James O'Keefe right that's right that
that organ I mean it's called project
Veritas but it was James O'Keefe yeah I
mean so the second he's gone what are
you donating to I mean he was it was his
investigative journalism and tactics
that people were were watching he was
the face of it the second that he was
gone what I just don't understand what
they thought would happen especially so
I mean today I know you said this you
know according to the reporting they
were fired they weren't fine I mean the
bottom line is they ran out of money I
mean I don't know all the finances but
like let's stop kidding around once he
left it dried up and at some point they
said we can't pay you anymore call it
what you will and why didn't they lead
off with firing their development team
the billions people are supposed to
raise money I think they have money but
I think money's not coming in because if
you look at their 990s they had millions
of dollars and so what's probably
happened is they probably looked at the
finances and said we got no donors we
got a couple million in the bank
at this rate we will be right totally
you know we'll be defunct in uh
insolvent in six months so he's like
okay fire everybody now and veritas will
function to some degree for a few years
but you know the funny thing is I I do
believe uh and obviously the the O'Keefe
Media Group uh that that he started
these people bought into a mission okay
they wanted to see things exposed
without
the project Veritas being any kind of an
alternative which right now this is
actually going to be a boon for him I
think because they're going to go okay
like let's just go back to basics I mean
maybe he stole someone's sandwich but
the bottom line is but the point is like
here's what we've invested in to begin
with let's go back to the OG yeah I
think his the employees actually that
are getting fired might actually go work
for O'Keefe Media Group and it's like no
no no
no they may
a little investigative journalism and be
like I have a video of you a tweet from
you and an email from you and you're not
working for me it reminds me of
Alexander the Great when he was on
campaign his men just got to the point
where they were fed up we're like we're
leaving and he was like fine leave so
they all he gave a speech and he was
like get out go go home tell him you
left me here and then a couple days went
by and the men like realized what they'd
done and they went back to Alexander and
begged to be let back because they were
starving and lost and maybe maybe he
gave this rousing speech and they all
realized like what they would be really
be leaving and here's here's what the
speech is pretty incredible and so he
took him back he took him back he's like
you're all my brothers this this reminds
me uh this has a touch of the uh an
element of leftism entitlement arrogance
James O'Keefe starts this organization
he sacrifices he gets raids raided by
the feds he gets sued over and over
again he's the the tip of the spear he's
the he's the front face uh the the front
man of this organization taking all the
Heat and working non-stop he brings
people onto a system at some point they
get in their minds that he's the bad guy
and they should take over and that
they'd be fine without him
and then it all comes crumbling down you
know what I find vaccinating by the way
so many times organizations uh like the
one that James founded you hear the
founder at some point starts to grift
they steal they get too big for
themselves that was never the case under
him as big as they grew as much money as
they brought in there's not I mean to
your point like this is a nitpicky thing
that they went after him on and I don't
know all the claims but it was never
about stealing or living the high life
or buying expensive cars and a couple
things were okay yeah they claimed it
like he paid his own wedding or
something like that but but okay and
or get to that point where they it
topples on itself he stayed true to the
mission
right and I think that that sort of is
an interesting thing for me to watch
because then he goes and does O'Keefe
Media Group and it's like all right and
he seems to have at least getting back
to getting enough people to help fund
that but uh I I just find it funny that
these guys thought that they could do it
without him yeah if you have a heart
issue don't rip your heart out I mean
that's the you got to heal the thing you
know have James sit down earlier point
if they're trying to keep this thing
going for a year or two you know you
fired your entire content team like the
people who are going to do the
investigative journalism which is
theoretically what people were donating
to support in the first place now you
have what an HR person and more people
fundraise like there's nothing there you
have lost sight of your mission they
they
they're wearing Veritas like a skin suit
and everyone can see right through it if
that's just it if James had been like
I'm gonna leave if it was his decision
and he was like everyone continue to
support this creation that I've been a
part of I think it would be fine I think
people would have stayed on yeah but
they stabbed him in the back and a bunch
of people who worked there signed a
letter stabbing him in the back despite
the fact the letter said some of us
haven't been witness to any of this nor
have we been ever been wronged by James
O'Keefe but we're signing the letter
anyway and it's like oh I was waiting
for this moment for for these people to
get their their comeuppance
I wonder how many of them do you think
James will hire any of them some of them
I bet some of them are probably just you
know like I don't have no idea I I bet
some of them are still encounter with
James with James saying I'm so sorry
this happened people who didn't sign
that letter accusing him of wrongdoing I
gotta tell you if I worked for Veritas
and I was uh you know out with James for
whatever reason and I bought myself the
most delicious chicken bacon ranch
sandwich and James walked up and says I
haven't eaten all day I need your
sandwich dude I'd be like bro no problem
I'd be like you're you're busting your
ass you're working really hard I will go
get another sandwich the idea that they
signed this letter of abuse because he
he allegedly took a sandwich I'm just
like you people are so petty that's the
that you know what man I'm glad that he
was able to get out and I'm I am glad
that he was able to start I believe I
believe OMG is a for-profit yeah of an
entity now good yeah now he has see the
problem with a non-profit first of all
James deserves as much money as he he
decides for the work that he does and
with a non-profit that they actually
you're limited right you have to when
you're filling out paperwork you have to
uh sign how much people are gonna get
paid are going to be are there going to
be any employees who make more than six
figures and I think the 990s showed that
James was getting around 300K per year
leading a what were they like an
eight-figure organization some of the
most influential with some of the most
vital and important groundbreaking
reporting the Amy rohrback story on
Epstein and here's James O'Keefe getting
you know like a mid-tier like VP salary
level which is hey it's good it's not
come out right a thousand dollars yes
but the level of influence and work that
he did he should decide if he wants more
but more importantly if James wants to
buy himself a Lamborghini I hope he does
he deserves it but as a for-profit
organization James can without any
question without any board members not
any legal paperwork choose to hire
whoever he wants fund whatever he wants
to launch documentaries do all of these
things and it's much much easier and
much much more effective for him to do
this he doesn't have to worry about now
so they accuse him taking too many black
cars night vehicles to and from and I'm
like yeah people want to kill this guy
the least you can do is give them an
Uber you know between locations and
they're like no it's wasting money he's
not like an executive at St John he
needs more protection but but get back
to the none of this the donors are
giving it to because of him yeah right
this is not like they installed this guy
and said wow we brought you into this
organization he built it he's getting
there the donors are buying into him and
his work
so if he wants to take a car here or
there to your point Tim about safety and
just efficiency Comfort yeah but this is
not again this isn't it's not like
they're like by the way he was taking a
G5 you know from from DC to his place in
the Hamptons this is I want I want a
black car that I know that the driver is
going to be safe that I'm gonna this is
not excess this is the benefit of a
private organization uh having a private
entity James will not be scrutinized for
saying hey we have so uh he came out
here a couple times and in order to do
so they had to do a private Charter I
think a private Charter for between here
in New York round trip is like 10 to 13
000. James is at that this level I've
explained to a lot of people there's no
way someone with a workload of James
O'Keefe is going to drive the six or
seven hours down here to come on the
show
or drive back or wait in the airport and
dedicate a whole day or two to travel
he's like hey I've got a bunch of
meetings today I can go on simple show
we got to get a private Charter we step
in we get the plane we're there in an
hour boom we're gone we're back in New
York the next day
to certain levels of of work and
responsibility require things like this
now don't get me wrong like when the
global Elites are like oh this climate
change is a big problem but they're
gonna find private jets yeah we can
criticize that I'm not going to
criticize someone for saying the only
way I can do this is if I if I get a
private Charter yeah I don't think the
logistics of his career are that
unreasonable especially if he has that
much to do I mean he has a a ton of risk
because he's just like a non-profit
leader he is a public face people are
very angry at the work that he does
there is more of a Target on his back uh
and I will say I think this is uh sort
of the the problem with nonprofits I
think a lot of people start nonprofits
because they see you know people can
donate to me and it's a tax write-off
and then I can get support I don't know
how I would make money off of this but I
do want to dedicate my life it's very
Mission driven but uh nonprofits are
ultimately ruled by a board and that can
be detrimental as we saw and they
betrayed him well let's uh uh I I I can
only say that it looks like OMG has been
doing a lot of work they've got
information I guess James has posted uh
coming out of Fulton County they've been
doing investigations and I think he's
now untethered and I think he's going to
be in better control and not have to
worry about being betrayed in the future
so good luck to him and uh you know you
hate to see it Veritas was an
institution it was it was a powerful
force that was doing really good work
and then it crumbled so it happens but
uh let's jump to more modern political
stuff the latest development in the
Trump indictments out of Georgia this is
from CBS 17 Trump lawyers seek April
2026 trial date in federal election
subversion case that's basically the
story the suggested date is a dramatic
counter to the doj to the Justice
Department's recommendation last week of
January 2nd oh I'm sorry this is the
federal judge I had this uh totally
wrong this is not the Georgia case this
is the federal election wait no no this
is a federal election says why do they
say a federal judge he's asking a
federal judge to intervene lawyers for
Donald Trump asked a federal judge
Thursday night to set an April 2026
trial date in the case in Washington
charging the former president with
conspiring okay right so this is this is
the Jack Smith case so this is the DC
case not the Georgia case man it's it's
hard to keep track of all these
indictments I thought this was Georgia
yeah then there's four but this I mean
look the reality is that they've got to
figure out something here because you
can't have the leading candidate for the
Republican nomination who's leading Joe
Biden having to deal with I mean they
can't have it both ways I I think the
one thing that that is lost in this
whole discussion and and I watched one
of the media organizations today try to
excuse this but the reality is every one
of those four cases
happened the the issue that he's being
charged with happened years ago why did
all four now happen it's weird
but I'm sitting here watching this
folders Joe County uh D.A go after him
for an event that happened two and a
half years ago why did it take and oh by
the way it just so happens to sequence
right after Jack Smith's case which just
happened to sequence after Jack Smith's
other case which happened to sequence
right after Alvin bragte all of these
events happened two and a half years ago
if what Trump did was so bad what new
has occurred nothing in Georgia they the
court published the indictments against
Trump before the grand jury convened but
that was a mistake sure yeah first I
said it was fictitious then they said we
hit the wrong button right but then
here's argument up Donald Trump came out
um I haven't seen the video but I saw
someone tweeting about it
apparently Donald Trump said that
everyone else should drop out of the GOP
Primary race that uh they should all we
should all be United and uh let me see
if actually let me let me pull up the uh
I can I can actually try and pull this
video up so someone asked I want to make
sure I get the person who has to write
I'll play the video for you guys
I didn't pull it up before but I'll pull
it up now
and uh let's see where we at
did I not did it not go through maybe it
didn't go through on my Twitter so
Trump apparently said that everyone
should drop out
and I think I think that's that's
correct I believe that all of the
Republicans should drop out of the race
Trump should be the only one and the
question is but what happens when they
remove Trump from the uh uh from the
ballots in various States I think Trump
should put that decision Dilemma to the
Democrats to say there is no one else
running for the GOP it is Biden or Trump
or Newsom or Trump whatever it's going
to be and they would have to remove
republican from the ballots outright if
they want to remove Trump right now if
there's other contenders there's a
safety net if it's Rhonda santis or
Vivek or anybody else if they remove
Trump from the ballot they'll put on
some other Republican so that way the
people who are there perceive this this
this option I think that's a that's the
decision dilemma either they a lot they
keep they're stopped from removing Trump
or they're forced to take such an
extreme and egregious action they will
shock people to their course
well I I mean I think the analysis might
be right but the reality is no each of
these guys who are running think somehow
that Trump's going to fall and they're
going to be the next person that's
what's keeping them in the race I mean
they all know I I made I don't want to
get ahead of the debate discussion if we
get there tonight but someone asked you
I get asked every day should Trump go to
the debate and I go he's at 54 in the
real clear average of polls most of
these folks need a name tag for you to
know who they are right so why should he
get on the stage and the same thing is
true they're all hoping that what you're
saying to him happens that he goes down
and they become the number two or the
number three the reality is that's all
they're hoping for they know they can't
win I mean no one at in their right mind
anyone who just has second grade math
says he's at 54. I'm trying to get to
one
I get it and that's even if you start
breaking it down by the states Iowa New
Hampshire it's not so they know their
only hope is that he falls down and gets
removed or something or gets the Vegas
has said no way to that and fake is
publicly resisting that saying I don't
want to win that way I want to win on
the merits and that we can't handle this
uh we can't handle this way so the Tweet
was from Jessie Kelly but I want to play
first the clip from Donald Trump here's
what Trump had to say great poll is just
out leading by 40 50 and even 60 points
who expected that I did Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina all very strong
but also leading Biden very big the
sanctimonious is crashing perhaps the
party should come together people should
drop out of the race we unify and we
beat Biden and the Democrats they should
be easy to beat because our country has
never been in worse condition
than it is right now thank you
so with this tweet from Jessie Kelly
says someone explained to me like I'm 10
you like I'm 10 years old how does
anyone dropping out help Trump stay out
of prison please be specific if everyone
drops out what do we do when the
Communists in Michigan and Pennsylvania
keep him off the general election ballot
my response was it creates a decision
dilemma for the Dems they either cancel
the GOP entirely or they keep Trump on
taking his name off would be apocalyptic
with others in the race they get a
safety net for new king Trump
if this goes back to what you said a
moment ago and this is or what we were
talking about I don't here's the deal I
think that you're right it's this
apoplectic decision I don't think they
care I think that they will do what and
this gets back to the nut of what I've
been saying is that they don't care they
will do whatever it takes to maintain
power then force them into a into a
risky position and what happens when we
this is my question what happens when we
lose meaning that they say great we're
going to remove them we're going to jail
them and then we're going to make sure
that Biden wins because no because you
need to avoid the frogs boiling in the
pot scenario if Donald Trump has taken
off the ballot and there are three
people standing behind him then the
ballot in Michigan still has Republican
and Democrat on it but if the ballot has
a single party and no one else that is
such a massive leap the problem we're
experiencing right now we mentioned this
in the beginning of the show every day
people say oh that can't happen that
would go too far you let's go way back
in time and I bring this up all the time
when I said in 2018 that the street
conflicts we are seeing between proud
boys and antifa were a track towards
Civil War and people laughed saying a
bunch of goons fighting in the street is
not a Civil War and I said yes but the
sentiments held by these people will
keep spreading eventually find their
ways into government and they said that
will never happen the security state
will not allow it where are we today
we're well past that point not only did
you have the 2020 Summer of Love riots
where they fire bombed they tried
firebombing the White House the
president was forced into a bunker you
then get January 6th you then get Donald
Trump being indicted several times every
single time someone has suggested that
something like this could happen people
have just across the board across
Twitter saying no that'll never happen
but that goes to the point that's my
that's what I'm saying you're absolutely
right so why is this time let me explain
so what's happening is every action they
take is them cranking up the temperature
by one degree you don't notice you're
boiling now that they've indicted
Trump's lawyers like Jenna Ellis what
was indicted simply for being his lawyer
counts one and two being party to a
criminal organization and violation of
public oath of office or whatever quite
literally just being his lawyer there
are people on that indictment list where
it's like they reached out to a state
elector and said they reached out to a
lawyer and said this no she's just a
lawyer
when when people said Trump wouldn't be
indicted Mike cernovich brings us up
he's like they're going to indict Trump
all of these people on Twitter these
prominent conservatives like no they
won't it won't happen then when it does
oh Trump gets indicted for what uh tax
paperwork some campaign contribution
that's not even a big deal the next day
it's classified documents okay well
that's you know it's not that big a deal
then it's trying to subvert the election
now they're going after his lawyers
what's happening is they're incrementing
it to such a degree that when they now
that they're at the point where they've
indicted lawyers for constitutionally
protected legal work people are acting
like it's no big deal yes so what you
have to do is put the Democrats in a
situation where they either take 10
steps forward or two steps back and 10
steps forward is like cranking the
temperature up past 400 degrees with
alls on the frogs shriek and jump out of
the pot imagine what would happen in
Michigan if your run-of-the-mill
bumbling dotted Republican voter who
doesn't pay attention goes and looks at
the ballot and there's not a single
Republican option or the president just
says Joe Biden that person goes what
this is where I'll disagree with you
because I think that what happens is the
media and the establishment in Hollywood
and everything else they own says well
unfortunately uh he committed these
crimes and he wasn't allowed to do it in
the Republican Party Bubba I mean they
do what they do I get your point I've
turned it up 10 notches doesn't change
anything anything make them
excise the Republican party from the
election force them to outright say you
have one choice or no choice it's the
same thing make them say it okay make
regular people have to let's play it out
for a second they say it the election
happens and they go see we did have an
election unfortunately the Republicans
had nominated a guy that was in jail and
we had to remove him from the ballot and
so Joe Biden has been dutifully elected
president of the United States for a
second time and oh by the way this is
where Kamal is coming in but I don't
know exactly what happens when they uh
when when does react this is what I'm
trying to get it when does when does
the frogs jump out of the pot they go oh
my God there's only one party and this
is what they're doing just what's the
recourse how do we undo what they did
this is the problem your your example
about the streets everything else and
everybody goes holy crap but we're not
even for all the stuff that they've done
and where we are in society no one's
turning back and saying we've got to
undo it now gosh look at how how hot it
got in the pot and I think they turn it
up a bunch of notches we freak out but
then we go what's the recourse we go oh
it's too late sorry next election so the
reason I believe the reason Democrats
are taking actions is Extreme is because
they know they've lost the culture yes
but my point is but but that means what
they're doing is irrelevant laws are
only enforced on the on the confidence
of the people and they're losing
confidence in people if they take one
party off the ballot outright confidence
evaporates overnight but see I think
that what your example was right they
they don't go hey in all 50 states
there's no Trump right it's Michigan
Pennsylvania right so it just prevents
him from getting to 270. um we did held
an election so what so so here's my
point so what is they declare him they
they go through the same exercise where
the uh the Congress certifies it and
they said sorry guys next time uh you
should nominate somebody you don't think
it'll happen absolutely that will not
that no way we as bad as 2020 was in
terms of how many how many members of
Congress challenged the results and
demanded action and and whatever you
think of January 6 we had something on
January 6 2024 will not go down like
that especially if they removed Trump
from the ballot in one state and just
one state my point is this the only
reason they get away with anything they
do is because people believe they can
so the example I like to give is that
women aren't legally allowed to skydive
in Florida on Sundays not a single cop
is going to arrest a woman for skydiving
in Florida on Sunday why because the
culture will not allow it we have tons
of laws in the books that never get
enforced it's illegal to do these drag
performances with children in a bunch of
these states ain't no cop stopping them
why because of the culture because the
cops are like I don't want to get
involved the sentiment of the people
matters more than what the letter of the
law says see just to just to bring this
back though for a second here's what I
think I I get your where you're going
with this but I think that there's also
a reality of where I in my opinion think
things are headed now which is that
either in DC or Georgia they get a
conviction
and what they do is they don't take them
off the ballot right that's this is my
take on this but they basically create
an environment to say Republicans you
guys do you really want to elect a guy
that's going to be in jail and so
they've the the elections are such that
Arizona Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin
are all within one two three four
percent you don't need to get 500 000
people against the president you need 10
20 40. Michigan was one in 2015 by Trump
by ten thousand seven hundred and three
votes that's it they get that they just
need a little movement of the needle and
they win they win Michigan they win so
what I think they're really doing is
ensuring that they get a conviction in
Washington DC and or in Fulton County
Georgia and that they can spread the
message that you guys are going to elect
a guy who can't get himself out of jail
I don't know and that to me is actually
a worse scenario because they can they
will let Republicans infight on that
whether or not and they don't have to
remove them from the ballot I don't I I
don't see that being as successful that
that is empiric Victory if Democrats
have to win using these methods they are
eroding the American people's confidence
in the system to function and that that
will destroy them that's my point
correct and that's how they lose yes
they have to maintain legitimacy yeah
but see here's my point you you talked
about the legitimacy look where we are
now you pointed out right where we are
in the streets and they're doing it
because of their desperation right
examples Bud Light
30 drop off in their stock 400 million
dollars lost Target 27 drop off in their
stock for the first time in six years
they're dropping in sales meanwhile
sound of Freedom surpasses Indiana Jones
Disney now facing major boycotts a rich
men north of Richmond to debut at number
one yeah because people are starting to
push back culturally and they're losing
so the only thing they have left is raw
power it won't work so let's ask
Republicans over the past 10 years if
political power did anything for him
with no cultural power so
on the sound of freedom and on on target
just to keep it one on one here you're
absolutely right sound of Freedom 100
what probably closing on to 200 million
right now and it's we people went out
saw the movie spread the word we want
Target same thing people were disgusted
by what they saw said I'm not shopping
in there but here's the question let's
look at Target who lost their job
my guess is cat bunch of cashiers but
that's my point is that this is what
scares me is it in any normal World a
decade ago you would have fired that CEO
and said what a you're out you
know who got fired a Bud Light
yeah the marketing team yeah marketing
no no just to be clear they didn't get
fired they're on leave no no they were
fired okay all right so the leave was a
lie reportedly fine but here's 5.5
people lost 26 what billion dollars lost
I mean and and five people lose their
job you've got everyone else in the
leadership well no uh Bud Light was
forced to sell off their craft brew
Brands to a Canadian company but my
point and they're shutting down several
of their plants and tons of okay so so
let's take this if Ian starts blowing up
Tim cast you're gonna get you know 20
minutes later he's out where where's the
accountability I mean yes they fired the
marketing team that's cowardness
they fired the people who did the thing
why don't you think their board demands
but that's this is where I get I mean
that's that's my worry that doesn't
matter it does because this is the point
that you're I don't care what Bud Light
does Bud Light could rehire the
marketing VPS and they could go and and
juggle bottles with a little Time Square
for all I care the fact is what we've
learned from this is that the American
people are turning things around right
that's all that matters but what I'm
curious about does what I what I'm
trying to say is that you're right I
agree with you on principle the problem
I have is that Target you look at that
this the CEOs and the top folks there
somebody should have paid the
consequence for this right who cares and
because because what I'm trying to do is
make an analogy to the Democratic party
here and say these guys keep going over
and over and over again right no one's
demanding that Chuck Schumer or Nancy
Pelosi or Hakeem Jeffries whatever go
hey guys your guarding is guiding us
down a path of of losing no it is
legitimately that they stay on it is
good that they're not doing that if
you've got a guy who's driving your if
the democracy Democrats are driving
their bus off a cliff
then then we should be saying like well
it's unfortunate that's their leadership
again agree with you I I'm like hey
let's keep them on board I love it but
this is what I'm trying to get at when
the point that I thought you are making
is that at some point they're gonna blow
themselves out right because they've
gone too far my question is when is that
because we keep learning that they've
gone too far they already went too far
it's done now they only have the
exercise of raw power they're desperate
for Trump supporters to act out and do
something and as long as we just keep
listening to good songs like rich men
north of Richmond and stop buying Bud
Light and shopping at Target eventually
they lose their power they lose their
confidence they're becoming desperate
already we're seeing corporations drop
ESG in name because they know it's bad
for their it's bad for their bottom line
What's Happening Now culturally is
Victory they're they're saying that
Disney's gonna Disney lose nearly 2
billion or something like that off their
their Passover releases they're failing
The Flash one of the biggest box office
bombs in history these institutions are
in free fall at the same time Angel
Studios with sound of Freedom not just
that the children it's huge yeah success
across the board
you you add on to the fact of what I you
know something I've been saying for
quite quite a bit the left is more
likely to abort their children and
sterilize their children no matter what
you think about indoctrination of kids
the math is absolute there there is
there's a rate of attrition among
leftists that does not exist among the
right which means 20 years from now it's
going to be two to one conservative to
Liberal voters even with indoctrination
it's and not to mention conservatives
are pushing back on the indoctrination
so what I see with Democrats the
indictment of Donald Trump their behind
the scenes crying looking at their their
their their their assets in Hollywood
failing their PR campaigns don't work
their woke garbage movies are being
mocked and ridiculed the celebrities
many of them are turning and being like
I I don't want to be involved in this
Dana Carvey puts out a video mocking
vaccines and people are starting to say
oh they're based Russell Brand Hollywood
celebrity now he's they're calling him a
he's right wing now it's like the
dudes a leftist they're losing right the
only thing they have left is the cudgel
it's not going to work so that's why I
say Donald Trump should be the nominee
the other nominees I think should drop
out I agree with Trump on this I'm not
like 100 saying everyone get out of it
I'm saying like there's a good point to
be made that if everyone drops out and
then Democrats are forced to use the
nuclear option of removing Trump from
the ballot that means there will be no
Republican now maybe they'll put a fake
Republican there or they'll just write
Republican or something but that would
be so shocking it would strike at the
core of whatever legitimacy they claim
to have right now I just don't think
they care I think they do whatever I
don't care I don't care if they care oh
I don't know
but what I'm saying is I think that
you're right but it's they're like they
think in in two and four year increments
so they're great we'll get past this
election then we'll deal with it it's
somebody else's problem if we completely
and then what will happen is eight years
from now they'll be saying we can't
muster up 30 of the vote what happened
it's like we weren't paying attention to
what was going on around us what will
happen is you'll get Democrats starting
do you wait eight years I'm not saying
it won't I'm not saying nothing will
happen between them yeah I'm saying
that's when they don't exist anymore
we're already at the point where you
have RFK pulling at 20 among Democrats
and RFK is actually trying to bring on
conservatives right into his Advisory
Board into his campaign because he wants
cross uh country appeal
that we're already seeing that among
Democrats they're fed up with this so I
I think whatever I the Chuck schumers
the Pelosi's these people they have they
were they were on a ship headed straight
into rough seas and they sat back eating
their 15 ice cream and now they're
caught in the storm and they can't get
out can I just give you the quick
political I can't help myself sometimes
because I think to your point about
where this thing ends up right now Trump
is leading an eye the only way that
Trump is not the nominee is if somebody
actually can beat him in an early State
Iowa New Hampshire South Carolina Nevada
right no right now exactly and that's to
so this gets to your point is in 2015
there were 29 days between uh the Iowa
caucuses and super Tuesday right this
time there will be 50 days why does that
matter campaigns need the equivalent of
gas what's gas money volunteers no one
is going to stick with a candidate they
can't defeat the nominee that can't
actually accumulate delegates and so
this gets back to what Hannah and you
guys we were all talking about before
understanding how this is going to play
out and Tim's going to get his wish
because going into Super Tuesday in
March these guys can't sustain
themselves no one's going to give
someone at one percent or two percent
money or or wake up and answer the
phones and put up signs and so Trump in
my estimation will be the nominee by the
time he hits super Tuesday in early
March so you're gonna get your scenario
politically speaking because there's no
one right now that can actually take
them on the only caveat that I've always
put is that Iowa is is an organizing
State meaning it takes about 50 000
people to win the caucuses desantis's
team claim that they've just over 10 000
people that have signed caucus
commitment cards if DeSantis can't do
that in Iowa it's over what do you think
about Rama Swami I'm impressed with I I
think I I as a as a political novice as
somebody's been doing this 30 years I
look at how he's conducting himself the
campaign that he's built and it's
impressive do I think he can win no he's
sort of like that quarterback that you
look at the beginning of the season and
say is he going to start or win a Super
Bowl no but that's the guy I want to
keep my eye on and he's the kind of guy
that I could see Trump picking as a VP
he's the kind of guy that I could see
running in 2028 I am impressed with the
organization uh that he's putting on I'm
impressed with the message and the
following the thing that's really
interesting for all these winders that
won't make the debate stage
vivec has raised of the total that he's
raised 2.7 million according to his last
thing from donors he's at six percent
he's ahead of the former Vice President
of the United States who is a governor
and a three oh a multi-term leadership
Congressman this just shows you that if
you have a good message and run a good
campaign you can't succeed he is proof
to all the whiners that won't make the
stage that it's you buddy yeah that's my
vibe I think Trump is so popular that
it's it's challenging to get the name
recognition at this point against an
incumbent essentially an incumbent
president even though he didn't serve
this last time I wanna I wanna talk
about where this uh Georgia indictment
goes because I think one of the most
important things to consider
we've been mentioning it several times
every time someone suggests the
Democrats may go one step further we're
told no that would be too far they won't
do it I think there is a strong
possibility that if Donald Trump
surrenders in Georgia
they will remand him to custody and
Severus Communications
I've heard people say oh that's crazy
they wouldn't do they're not going to
remind him why why not think think about
what they're doing right now and going
after someone's lawyers
if if you were to tell me that Donald
Trump would be indicted let's say let's
say a year and a half ago Trump's going
to be indicted I'd be like well I
wouldn't put it past him if you then
came to me and said yes they're also
going to indict as lawyers I'd be like
what now that's a step too far if he
said okay they're not gonna indict his
lawyers but when they indict him they
are going to put him in jail and and
revoke a bail I'd be like yeah that
makes sense they're arresting him so why
would we assume that it is more
reasonable to expect his lawyers and
former administrative Administration
staff to be indicted under Ricoh charges
then to assume it would be uh that it
would be less like why would we assume
the probability lies not with him being
remanded to custody and the probability
lies with lawyers being indicted what
worries me more than anything
in this case at your point is it this
Fulton County D.A doesn't have anyone to
answer to right so they they and by the
way Governor Kemp down there George is
not doing Trump any favors so the point
is if she goes down the route that
you're talking about Tim that's where
people have to understand that I I think
she doesn't care she's a Democrat that's
good that has no there's nothing in her
that cares what Donald Trump or anyone
else thinks she wants to be a hero to
the left and I think that gives Merit to
exactly what you're saying is that she's
like I can be a hero I'm the guy that's
going to put Donald Trump Behind Bars
I'm going to get the mug shot and it'll
be me I will be the hero to the
progressive left doing this and I don't
have to worry about answering anybody I
don't answer to doj I don't answer so I
think that to to what you're getting at
this is going to be the key moment when
he goes to Georgia and he will
what happens then because they're going
to do things to him in the last three
that haven't happened and everyone's
gonna go oh my gosh I I hope he gets a
remanded to custody and I think people
need to realize Trump said I need one
more indictment to win the presidency
I wonder if Trump is surrendering
because he gets this that every time the
Democrats take these extreme actions
they're stripping themselves of con of
the confidence of the American people
that people are starting to view what
they're doing as illegitimate you've got
even some percentage of Democrats who
feel that the charges are overtly
political or going uh you know way too
far so Trump may be thinking
in this in this day and age we're in the
victimhood you know uh era or whatever
the idea is if you want to win a fight
you don't throw a punch you wait to get
punched and then scream help help I'm
being oppressed so Donald Trump says hey
I'm obeying the law goes you know and
and goes through the arraignment the
arrest process the mug shot and then
uses this to say they are evil and
corrupt and their only path to Victory
is through violating our social norms
never in this country's history has a
political uh has a president targeted
his political opponent Trump's going to
weaponize this for fundraising and for
sentiment and to strip the Democrats the
Democratic voter of confidence I look I
I think that the the point that I'm
taking away from this is that what
happens in those 20 minutes after he
shows up is going to be really
interesting I mean they're they're
almost giddy that sheriff was like you
know we we're he's definitely going to
go to mugshot like what do you need a
mug shot for right the most famous man
in the world does not need a mugshot
can fundraise the rest of their
political career but this is the point
exactly you're spot on this is all about
trying to be the most Progressive person
out there they're all vine the sheriff's
trying to out through the D.A the D.A is
trying to outdo this that's what worries
me more than anything else is that these
guys I I when when Alvin Bragg did his
first indictment
as a non-lawyer I was talking to some
folks that are very well versed in this
all stuff and I said here's what I don't
get you know this venue how do you mix
it and they said Sean I want you to
understand something ever since Trump
became president
it's like the rules have changed what
normally would have made sense you had
said okay this isn't the right venue
that this is they don't have standing
this that the other thing they go Katie
Bar the Door baby judges don't care
anymore it's like oh it's Trump or
you're a trump associate or we're going
after okay like things that would have
never passed the smell test
four or five years ago and and that's
what worries me that's why I say Civil
War
the only the only thing where so uh
Stephen Marsh says this we're in this
period of civil Strife civil Strife has
appeared before Civil War when there's a
certain number of political deaths that
occur every year and we've exceeded that
number over the past few years so by the
actual historical metric the argument is
the experts say we are entering a Civil
War and not we don't know when it will
start or what'll kick it off my view is
that's probably true and correct and
it's a fair assessment
but there is also the consideration of
fourth and fifth generational Warfare
which is psychological operations and
manipulation
if the Democrats are are doing as
exactly as you described they are saying
the rule of law doesn't matter the
Constitution doesn't matter we don't we
don't care about what your witness says
I mean look in in Georgia they released
the indictment on Trump before the grand
jury even voted there but they clearly
have fabricated this for political
purposes you but this is the thing that
I find fascinating right they post it
and then they lie about it right they
literally were like oh that was a you
know uh fictitious fictitious then it
comes out again and then they get caught
lying again about what it was this is
what blows my mind no one cared
like the idea I don't think that's true
no no no we did okay but the idea that
no major Network said they just got
caught in a lie this is what that and I
know that let me try this France didn't
care right
the people the people of France didn't
care at all that this information came
out right that's how you need to start
viewing the Democrats
right they they they do not care about
the Constitution about your voting
process right they wrote an article in
Time magazine called The Shadow campaign
to fortify the election how they and
they basically broke down how the
election and the choice of the people
are meaningless to their whims yeah so
when you say no one cared no you're
talking about the people of France if
you're in if you're England and you're
in confident conflict with France it's
surprising to be like can you believe
the people of France don't care that the
king just passed this decree well of
course they don't care no but don't live
in Georgia can I just ask this and I'm
being serious here that I get it like
I've lived this for 30 years of double
standards hypocrisy okay but this gets
to I think the nut of what you're saying
where it's like at some point I'm like
you've got to be kidding me they
literally went through the motions and
and I there's I always think there's
going to be at least some degree of fake
outrage like oh my gosh this happened no
one from the major networks even
acknowledged it happened if it wasn't
for like you guys and some folks in in
uh for the future but I just and again
maybe everyone like the idea that we
continue to go you've got to be kidding
me because the goal posts keep getting
moving farther and farther away from
what I expected reality I used to get
the everyone always talks about how you
know the the Evening News used to be no
way they didn't it never was fair they
just faked it better right I mean that
was and everyone played the game now but
the reality that no one even tries to
fake it anymore like the faux outrage of
like oh this happened because you're at
War well but I just and again I call me
naive but I'm literally going I've been
watching this for 30 years and seeing at
least people pretend that that there's
some modicum of real like outrage the
idea that a court published this no one
said anything but people do care and I
mean we we experience it and my
experience over the past few years with
extended family and friends
few years ago the people a lot of the
extended family they were passive
liberal passive anti-trump today they
are passive anti-democrat what I mean by
passive is they don't pay attention for
the most part they're not going on
Facebook and posting memes about it
they're not on Twitter a few years ago
they were saying things like oh Trump is
so awful I can't stand them today what
do I hear from them oh I'm so sick of
the Democrats I'm so sick of this their
crime is running rampant and you ask
them like you're gonna vote for Trump I
don't know about that but they're no
longer in the position where they're
like Trump is evil and must be stopped
so here's what I think may occur
they may still get their default
anti-trump votes but I think a lot of
regular people
you don't have coveted lockdowns anymore
and you don't have a scapegoat Trump was
the president they can say all your
problems are Trump's fault yep now
Biden's a president so you're going to
be you're gonna have a very very
difficult time to go to the exact same
people and say remember everything we
promised you and didn't deliver on vote
for it again they're gonna be like I
don't even know anymore I'm out or when
you look at what's going on with the
raids where these gangs are raiding
Nordstrom and the Nike store people look
there's that lady in Portland she got
cracked in the face with a with an
aluminum water bottle and then she's
like I'm voting Republican now and I'm
like well I'm surprised they're getting
smashed in the face perhaps you know for
many people it was the Chas but I think
things are getting so bad both in in
people's personal lives and in the
political space it's going to cost them
dearly I think Trump knows this and I
think that's why Trump said I need one
more indictment to win and I think the
reason why he's playing along and just
doing everything is because he's playing
the Martyr route let them be the
villains in the evil empire and I'll be
the underdog fighting the machine
I hope so well all that really matters
is this
will the Republican party will Donald
Trump build the biggest ballot
harvesting and chasing machine ever ever
seen in this country because if they
don't then sentiment means nothing and
that's the key this is why I was telling
you I I'm launched in this new show
because I people have to understand how
to win we sit back and everybody goes I
don't like ballot harvesting I want to
vote on Election Day I think there's a
reason we have election day we've lost
the battle
right everyone now is mailing in their
ballot and this is what the Dems outdid
Us in covid it was they they cheated
they changed the laws they didn't I mean
they didn't abide by any of the local
regulations they threw out any lawsuit
that challenged their correct and so the
reality is that either you get up and
now say Okay ballot harvesting is legal
we're gonna start getting all these
people registered the way like we've got
to understand the rules and play by them
but but understand that this is how
they're playing by them and if we don't
do it then we're going to continue to
lose I keep looking back at Georgia do
you realize if we had won that race in
Georgia we wouldn't have any of the
issues in terms of the Biden nominee so
we had the judges the nominees the
oversight would start happening
okay but here's the point enough people
in Georgia didn't get out there and do
it and if we don't realize the
consequences of these elections we're
going to get stuck with these policies
and these people that are ruining the
country we saw a lot of sentiment from
people in Georgia and that Senate runoff
that said what's the point of voting
anyway it's all fraud yes well
congratulations your fraud narrative
suppressed your own vote correct
I'm still I mean I'm I'm not going to
claim that there is fraud but I cannot
stand the idea of voting on an electric
voting machine the proprietary code
tallies my vote I put that in quotes
behind the scenes so it's like I throw a
rock into the ocean and there someone
else is gonna be like oh yeah your rock
landed over there trust me republicans
in Congress should pass a bill Banning
the use of proprietary voting absolutely
need the code to be free because I have
evidence of a developer who's testifying
in front of a Judiciary Committee that
he built uh technology to flip the vote
5149 in 2000.
um it's it's sickening that famous
famous footage yeah yeah let me but more
importantly there's a there was a there
was a a story about a guy who got a
speeding ticket and he went to court and
he said he wanted the source code of the
radar gun because for all we know it's a
random number generator and you have to
prove prove being a reasonable doubt
that that thing actually showed my speed
and the judge was like you're right yeah
man how do we know that thing does what
people claim to do Clinton Eugene Curtis
testified that he for Congressman Tom
Feeney in 2000 built the Prototype
software package that would secretly rig
an election to sway the result 5149 in
2000 and then I think George Bush won
that election 51-49 we don't very
strange yeah we don't know and that's
the problem is we don't know I'm saying
we don't know what voting machines do
nobody does
all we know is you have a machine we
have various machines where you can tap
a screen and it claims you voted but I
have no idea what's going on like
why would I make that assumption the the
software code for any voting machine
should be publicly available to
everybody more importantly I think due
to the complexity of it they should be
outlawed outright also foreign
there's no benefit
well the I mean just so you understand I
mean the answer is because they're going
to claim that that there's no federal I
mean that these are all state-run a lot
I mean that's their I'm not explaining
I'm right now you're right right states
have a right they have a right to they
each run their own elections and
therefore we're not we don't have any
over which is but they again this is
sort of like uh the the drinking age
there is no federal law that says it's
21 but they just tell everyone
Transportation dollars flow to states
that have a 21 so they tie the money so
you can do it
but they just don't want to and the
reality is but look can I just get back
to the bottom line is I and I don't I'm
not there's a there's a discussion to be
had on what you and Ian are bringing up
but the point is is that too many people
are saying well until that's done I'm
not voting or and that's what happened
in Georgia well guess what then we lose
so you can do both at the same time you
can basically say all right I'll get out
there I'll play by the current rules and
we need to fix it but if we keep losing
elections they're just going to keep
steamrolling us I thought I thought for
sure Hillary is going to win 2016
because I'd given up I was totally black
build like well I can't prove it they
were so convinced that Trump didn't have
any I think part of it was they didn't
have their guard up they were like
there's no way this is gonna happen
and they want kind of in 2020 they were
like all right that's why we're going to
keep changing these rules Wisconsin
Nevada Jordan they was like okay let
Pennsylvania's Constitution doesn't
allow early voting
right they just did it anyway they just
did it and then the Court ruled it was
fine yeah we got but we got some efforts
here let's pull up this story we got
this from the post millennial Georgia
state senator moves to impeach Trump
prosecutor Fannie Willis Moore said we
must strip all funding and if
appropriate impeach Fanny Willis so he
uh dreaded this letter I believe uh oh
they don't they don't have it he said we
the undersigned being the duly elected
members of the Georgia house House of
Representatives and Georgia Senate and
comprising three-fifths of each
respective house pursuant to article 4
section 2 paragraph 7B hereby certify
you in writing with a copy to the
Secretary of State that in our opinion
an emergency exists in the Affairs of
the state requiring a special session to
be convened under that section for all
purposes including uh for all purposes
to include without limitation the review
in response to the actions of Fanny
Willis so this is a Georgia Senator
Colton Moore who apparently went on to
say that they must defund or impeach if
appropriate now I'm not entirely
convinced they'll do anything I don't
trust Georgia Republicans at all but
I'm curious where this goes I'm not so
sure this ends with Trump simply
surrendering we've already got Mark
Meadows filing to have this move to
Federal Court a bunch of analysts
believe that will happen very very
quickly uh you've got John Eastman
severing his his case from the rest of
the group saying his defense is
different from theirs and then you've
got
the attempts to remove the prosecutor I
think Donald Trump should immediately
his lawyer should be filing a claim this
is interesting to me because why isn't
this happening should be the first thing
we heard his lawyers file with the
federal government on the challenging
the constitutionality of trying to have
him arrested right that should be the
first thing that happens for a state in
a state court for a federal election but
apparently Trump is agreeing to
surrender he's apparently negotiating
there's a bigger point I grew up in
Rhode Island where organized crime Rico
was used largely for organized crime in
the ma in Mafia right the idea that you
are now and you made this point about
Jenna Ellis a while ago there are people
who if you read the indictment and what
they're being charged with the different
counts and indictment it's like tweeted
did this Representatives they are
creating a criminal Enterprise under a
statute that was made to go after
organized crime because mob bosses would
Escape because they're like ah
technically I didn't do that or whatever
but this is I I've been involved in two
really close elections 1994 uh was
involved in a race that lost by 21 votes
on Election night and then 2000 we one
by 386 votes the first thing you do is
you're out there claiming that you won
you're making sure that you exhaust
every recourse in terms of petitioning
the government talking in like they
nothing that they did in this case
is less than expressing yourself under
the laws that exist in our constitution
to to participate in a democracy they
are creating a criminal Enterprise by
saying this is this goes back to what
we're talking about this is how far
they're going yeah
it feels like a sort of slip on George's
part right they see them as criminals so
they're going to make them into
criminals you even saw Chris Christie
who is literally all he talks about of
his entire campaign is Trump no Trump no
more Trump his entire he came out and
said this is a mistake how they're
handling this because I think again
they've they've jumped the shark they
keep going one step further and in her
case it was because I want to show
everyone in the world that I can be the
champion that slays the Dragon
yeah and they've got unhinged supporters
on social you you know I think one big
component of the culture War has been
that Fringe weirdos on social media
drive the conversation among Democrats
and when they started Banning
conservatives something interesting
happened
you've got I want you to imagine there's
two kids one's filthy and covered in
chocolate ice cream all over his face
and it looks like a disaster and the
other kids very clean looking and you
know his hair is parted perfectly he's
wearing a nice little suit and you think
man that kid's you know well well
educated well well taken care of and
well developed and Advocate is
something's wrong with them you assume
the dirty kid is got something wrong
with them the reality is the mother just
does not let the other kid have
chocolate ice cream and if he can't get
access to it he can't get all messy the
other kid she lets him have it so what
we're seeing with the censorship on
Twitter they kept allowing the left to
say the craziest things imaginable but
the right would be banned instantly what
happened is you got a perception of the
right as Ben Shapiro saying well listen
you know these are the arguments we're
gonna have they're completely on the
taxes and it's very basic very normal
conservatism on the left you have people
arguing that you can be a chimp if you
want you just need to get the
appropriate surgery and so now you end
up with post-liberals and and uh
disaffected liberals people people who
are like I can't associate with this
Democratic politicians on social media
are adhering to the voices of the most
Fringe and insane personalities and
people on the right were listening to a
bunch of regular moderately conservative
individuals this made Democrat
politicians sound like crackpots when
they start advocating for child sex
changes and sex chose for sex shows for
children now you get regular people
being like yo that that's crazy that's
too far for me
because they were allowed to say these
things and social media wouldn't ban it
yeah well think about it you brought up
sound of Freedom before I I uh I started
before I actually saw the movie I
started going what's all this Q Anon
stuff right I finally watched the entire
movie I'm like I'd seen the clips I'd
watch the trailer I talked to a bunch of
the guys and then I kept saying like I
just don't get the Q Anon thing no I I
mean literally if you watch but this is
what they do they demonized it and what
happened is more people said I gotta
watch it it became unbelievably
successful but they they they don't know
where to stop Q Anon it has there's
nothing like but that used to be the
thing they would say to keep people away
from service they're saying that about
Oliver Anthony they're saying he's a q
Anon guy wait they're still using it I'm
just saying it's not as effective as it
used to be before when you would say Q
Anon people would be like Ah that's
that's crazy internet stuff and now you
say q9 people are like oh that means
mainstream people in the media don't
like it and therefore maybe I should
check it out on my own there is a
Reawakening of curiosity and it didn't
work like people went and saw that movie
in droves yeah and they're still going
175 million basically yeah beat beating
Indiana Jones and a bunch of other films
probably the top box office for the year
absolutely incredible and the budget was
really small so it's actually performing
way better than we can even realize some
of these movies it's like oh it made 500
million dollars and it cost 600. yeah we
don't come on sound of Freedom was 15
million it's at 175 million and again
Bud Light and all these other things
I I think we win culturally and then
what happens is Oliver Anthony is a
really great example John Rich tweeted
this out that all these labels are
tripping over themselves trying to get
him on board or sign with him but if he
he said if if Anthony was signed to
these labels they wouldn't let that song
Right you'd never hear it yeah no why
don't you write a song about drinking
beer with your dog in your truck because
your girl left you or something not
about miners on an island or whatever
now that's that's a bit too much so
it's a Grassroots effort but the culture
matters because money talks and Bs walks
Disney and all these organizations
they're losing money
they're going to have to fall in line or
their money is going to dry up
yeah that was similar is that the money
like Alex Jones got slammed I don't know
if slander's the right word but he got
you know demeaned in the media got
talked badly about then he got deleted
from Twitter uh but then when they went
after his pocketbook that's when it
really stifled his ability to create now
he's working for Stephen Crowder I think
he's working with me he has a special
with mug Club but Alex Jones and
Infowars are all still doing their thing
but they just shredded his organization
financially and caused him so much
stress for years and they see they're
doing Donald Trump through the legal
system like you can talk crap about
someone only so long before it turns
against you but if you go after Finance
I think that is a way to permanently
destroy someone's ability to communicate
yeah doesn't Alex Jones oh like the GDP
of France or something billions of
dollars it makes it I mean I would think
if you were the the people suing him you
know you're never gonna see that money
so if you really felt like you needed it
to fund whatever
whoever is acting on your behalf is
actually trying to make a political
point and presumably they are also in on
it I think that's the whole point of our
justice system right now especially
because so much of it plays out uh in
the court of public opinion it's not
about actual Justice or figuring out
what's right or wrong it's about getting
the much mug shots about getting the
perp walk it's about getting headlines
being able to say well I was the one who
filed charges I was the one who did this
I served on that jury and we did this
thing and therefore I have the moral
superiority and that's it people feel
like they have influence they just want
a Wikipedia page man I'm thinking lights
all they want like how Alex sacrificed
uh his financial you know stability or
had it it was sacrificed on the altar in
front of him and he watched and watched
it happen it's like the founding fathers
of the United States they they risked
everything man they risked their
fortunes as well like at some point you
speak out against it they might shut
your bank account off but like you got
to take that risk if you if you want to
speak what you believe there's a risk
involved and there's probably the risk
will probably intensify in the come
coming
five years probably by 2027 we're going
to see a sea change that's when graphene
goes Peak I think that's when money
might not be that become way way less
important I think the value of money
actually is going to be can continue to
diminish we'll see what happens with
that I mean uh Michael burry we talked
about the other day made a big bet
against the S P 500 and NASDAQ and so
everyone's kind of like looking around
like does he know something exactly he
doesn't mean he does he got he got the
mortgage-backed Securities things right
in 2008 doesn't mean he's a prophet
means he got one big one right
I don't know I don't know if I want to
hope he's right this time or not I mean
a shock to the system could be good it
could be bad I have no idea I think
ultimately the scary thing is it's going
to negatively impact working-class
people who are already having a hard
enough time buying groceries
yeah I'd just like to know when that's
gonna happen
second plan well SpaceX what SpaceX sold
all their Bitcoin today or something
like that are they really and then the
price of Bitcoin collapsed and then they
announced ETF uh ethereum ETF or
whatever Futures and then it jumped back
up so it's like yeah everyone would have
loved to have known that SpaceX was
about to sell off their Bitcoin so they
could get out before price went down but
yeah everything dropped six percent
let's uh let's go to let's go to the
good news ladies and gentlemen from
Rolling Stone oh they're seething over
this Oliver Anthony's populist
polarizing rich men north of Richmond on
track to debut at number one the
Virginia upstart song about rich
politicians and poor people abusing
welfare is already at the Atop The
iTunes Spotify and apple music charts
he's got what are they saying 98 000
digital song sales 7.8 million streams I
don't know uh where that'll put them on
the hot 100. it is very it is very uh
difficult to uh to to top that sharp but
they say Morgan wallen's last night the
reigning number one from this week's
Billboard Chart and one of the biggest
hits of the year has 13 million streams
but just over 3 000 digital sales with
41 million AirPlay Impressions it's a
major year for the genre blah blah blah
all right so let's let's break this down
I could be wrong in my math but I
believe that one sale is 1 500 streams
so do the math and you'll calculate how
many streams uh
that uh Oliver Anthony actually has but
that 41 million error I would say
airplane Impressions that's hard to beat
that's basically the radio station
saying we'll play your music and of
course they're not gonna get Oliver
Anthony on there it's going to be very
difficult now with the weight of the
song they might be forced to oh yeah but
you know why he's uh you know I have a
real simple reason
why this song is doing so well and why
they're so mad about it
what did the corporate music industry
give us in terms of music
wet ass
yeah okay that's the stuff that they
tell you to listen to okay fine Adele is
up there somewhere and Taylor Swift and
then you have that teeny bopper stuff
from Harry Styles or whatever it's not
only just WAP or whatever but this is
the antithesis of web
so this is something that regular people
who are sick of the disgusting Sodom and
Gomorrah music and entertainment
industry can now be like hey there's
some music hey I understand this hey
these words mean something to me and
that's pushing back so this you combine
it with all the other cultural Endeavors
we've been winning on and
just feels good you know what I thought
was fascinating you you put the headline
up from Rolling Stone for the first I
don't know maybe 24 48 72 hours he was a
phenomena everybody was excited and then
once the folks from the right John rich
and others sort of talked about him and
made him a cause the the Rolling Stones
of the world suddenly branded him it was
like oh God we we were initially
positive on this guy the second the
people on the right embraced him
what's the headline polarizing he was
polarizing in Q Anon because but for the
first 24 hours he was a rock star and
you know a savant and you know this it
was but it was so funny to watch how
quickly they shifted once folks on the
right embraced the message and his
success they're like if you guys like
him we hate it exactly there's nothing
to do I mean I for one love to see
Ginger representation I think redheads
don't have enough uh place in the media
uh yeah I feel like we should credit him
as a representing a very
um uh minority genetic group yes thank
you Serge uh but I think part of it too
is at least for me again this is the
sort of the alternative country folk
genre that I personally already like uh
but I think he's talented right we so
much of what's sort of AstroTurf right
now in pop pop music is just like the
same one verse with one Bridge it's all
kind of electronically done and maybe
those singers and artists and
songwriters have some Talent on some
level but because it's supposed to
appeal to the masses they try to make it
as simple and as you know your wormy as
possible whereas this is actually catchy
he's actually got a good voice he's
actually a talented musician and that's
more effective instead of sort of trying
to make it this garbage song giving
something something with giving the
people something with feeling is really
having an impact so I have a correction
it's not 1500 it's 150. for every sale
of Richmond north of Richmond that
counts as 150 streams
so he's currently sitting at uh with
with these numbers
yeah we're looking at about
22.5 million streams
he's not going to beat this these other
radio uh radio guys now he would you
know the song only has 13 million
streams and 3 000 sales that ain't
nothing but they've got the radio behind
them so I can only tell you this man if
you really like the song you all need to
go on iTunes and buy it if that and tell
all your friends to buy it because if
you're going to listen to it if and look
we've talked about it with our music and
everything but I'm gonna say this right
now I know you all love this song I love
this song it's a great song I was I
planning on Loop early I was like damn
this song's fantastic
buy it spend that dollar buy it go on
iTunes buy the song tell all your
friends to buy the song anyone you know
who listens to it you say hey man let's
make this guy the Superstar let's make
him bigger than than cardi B bigger than
Taylor Swift all you got to do is spend
a dollar that one dollar counts as 150
streams let's get this song to debut
Platinum I think he needs uh 75 to 150 I
think he needs 150 million he needs he
needs just about eight times where he's
currently at in terms of streams and
purchases so right now they're all
seething they're they're trying to argue
that he's a plant yes look at this
intelligence intelligence or look at
this Oliver Anthony in the incoherence
of right-wing populism they're losing
their mind over a factory worker termed
farmer who wrote a country Acoustic Song
it didn't do anything to anybody he
wrote a song about how he feels and they
are losing their minds but this gets
back to the Bud Light the target uh
right in the last 24 months give or take
I I feel like conservatives have gotten
their sea legs we go out there and go
guess what we're not going to take it
we're not going to shop or we're not
gonna buy you and then conversely sound
of Freedom Oliver Anthony we go out
there and go all right we support them
this is what's I think we have finally
starting to get get it together you
actually don't want like something then
stop going into the store stop buying
the product don't just say ugh the heck
with it and for the things that we do
like and Tim you're absolutely right you
go out you spend that buck at some point
they can't ignore it and that's what
happened with sound of freedom and and
frankly before that the Chosen and I
know they've got a bunch more in the
works at Angel Studios but that's what's
happening with this guy as well it's a
dollar to make a difference and that's
what's going on is I I just I get
excited when I see success stories like
this because it just shows that we can
do it and I think that's frankly what's
going on in media too I tell people all
the time go look at what you guys are
doing at Tim Cask look at what Patrick
but David's doing all of these folks
that the media doesn't want to pretend
exist are unbelievably successful and
that's why I'm doing what I'm doing it's
like you know what I'm tired the
corporate stuff it's it's not where the
future is anymore and I think if we band
together and support each other when
events like this come along this is
where I think we start to win again
I love uh Oliver Anthony's performance I
think that that song is pretty simple
it's like a verse course Verse Chorus
and it's just ends after that so there's
no Bridge there's no three parts that
you would consider to make a hit but the
way he performs it is so real visceral
less is more it changes you and like
it's the kind of thing where he could
tell you a bedtime story and it would be
invigorating because of the way he tells
it post Malone's like that this guy's
like post Malone's got that posty energy
I love it he needs one million sales to
be platinum you need 150 million streams
for platinum I hope I hope this song
gets there yeah it's like the biggest
song in the world so where is he at
right now what's the 20 some odd million
and 98 000 sales so he's at 10 of the
sales needed look debuting at Platinum
is a big ask songs songs go platinum
after like a few years then they're like
hey you finally reached that you cross
that Mark where you know you've you've
got enough plays of your song but it
would be cool if he could do it because
he seems like someone who has strong
values I mean he posted earlier today
that he's uh launching you know merch
for for this with a local t-shirt
company from wherever he's from in
Virginia like Farmville I think that's
cool Farmville Farmville May's from
Farmville yes and now you understand why
people like plant you know what I mean
uh we live in a simulation but I I like
that he is saying like I I want to
support other small businesses and I
think that is cool to see it would be
very easy for him to be like people want
my stuff let me figure out the fastest
way to get to them or the big
Corporation they can help me out and I
wouldn't I I would understand why you
would do it I just like that he's opting
to work locally and small that's a value
that I would want to see in my own life
check this out they say uh Fox News
Oliver Anthony says he's turned down
eight million dollar offer since going
viral nothing special about me yeah dude
stay independent brother all right just
I will Roger up if you want to give me
eight million dollars
um
cancel your show it's not worth it if
you saw me dance my singing's worse than
that uh dude I I listened to his song
like four or five times this rich man of
north of Richmond and it was like the
fifth time I listened to it something
struck me like I just started shaking I
was like I got Goosebumps all through my
body for like almost the entire song but
sometimes that's what it takes a few
times you listen to something or you eat
something a few times and it's a fire
taste it's real music yeah so much music
because we've been putting out music Let
Me Explain you guys we talked to these
industry dudes and they say you gotta
get on the dsps the Digital streaming
playlists once you're there they'll
automatically play your song for people
if it's in a certain genre and then
you'll start getting play and I'm like I
get it if you're in the machine if you
are approved by the people who work for
Pandora for Spotify or whatever if
you're well known they'll Auto load your
new song it will be guaranteed to get a
certain number of hits and then you're
going to chart yeah all the stuff we had
to do when we released Songs and we
charted was asking people to to to to
like hey be active listen to our music
so we're fighting through this machine
that props up everybody else Oliver
Anthony has hit the dream
he has 17 million hits on you on YouTube
000 sales the equivalent of about 15
million 14 uh 14 million 700 000. so
he's looking at 30 plus million streams
all organically with no industry support
because he wrote a good song that
resonates with people yeah nailed it
yeah it's awesome and I look I mean it's
got 19 million on YouTube now Millions
three million in one day radio WV where
I saw this video originally does stuff
with other artists like he sort of I
hope he does well individually I don't
want to take attention away from him but
like he is representational of a whole
group of artists who probably don't get
the attention from mainstream Outlets
because they are not exactly what
they're looking for and I think it's
cool to have someone who's sort of
opening the door and saying you know it
feels like it becomes that thing if you
like this music you can probably figure
out other artists that you can support
that are similar to him and I think Tim
you mentioned that he didn't have
industry support but I think he has an
industry support it's just a new kind of
industry it's a decentralized Creator
industry yeah like Jack kosovic people
that fire out his music to 100 000 views
I think I think the video is actually
posted to some kind of
Music Channel yeah it is uh radio W
right it's small I mean there's another
one
um I think it's called gemstone VHS like
if you like this style of music you can
kind of find it but I think you're not
entirely wrong it's not like the mega
big Studio or I can't even it's very
different you might be well knowing your
genre you might grow but I don't know of
anyone else who sort of launched into
this stardom from these smaller groups
are doing great work they didn't
understand too so he's got this Facebook
post where he said people in the music
industry give me blank stares when I
brush off eight million dollar offers
they're not offering you eight million
dollars no that's usually just an
advance too and then you get a million
dollars you have to pay back the amino
dollars after you've made your record
sales and like they think he could do it
and this because in this case he could
probably do that but they're saying most
people this was one song we could take
all your music yeah we put on an album
we put advertising behind it we're gonna
give you eight million dollars and then
what happens is they give you eight
million dollars to be paid back right
and then you got to pay for pay back all
the marketing payback you know all the
placement pay back the managers the
manager gets cut and then after all of
your albums sell they're like here's
your 15 cut of the 10 million dollars we
made off the album you're gonna get one
million but that's gonna go back towards
the debt you have with us so you
actually owe us seven million dollars
have a nice day exactly that's how it
goes and you can't say anything more
about these uh Elite stuff like here's
what you're gonna write now yeah yep
exactly it's funny how they're calling
him a plant but it's like it's just not
it's just so obviously not the case
especially returning that down it's such
desperation his name is Christopher
Anthony Lunsford
his grandfather is Oliver Anthony
music is dedicated not only to him but
1930s Appalachia where he was born and
raised oh that's awesome yeah she's the
best chrysanthe he says he GLA I'll
gladly go by Oliver because everyone
knows me as such amazing this is that's
really cool music coming out of
Appalachia I feel like there's a whole
Renaissance here in terms of music I I
mean it's just because you it's not what
Hollywood is expecting but there is re
there are a lot of really interesting
artists that are based clean air it's
easier to breathe here it's easier to
sing I was in LA for way too long
there's too much brake dust in the Earth
but it's different values it's not the
same thing like you're not hearing
another song about like a party of
people trying to get famous not that
those aren't real experiences the most
horrifying song of all time do you know
when you look at movies
that are solid content good values
Family Values Christian values
name one that hasn't done well
they all do what the pro this is the
funny thing is this song is another
example of this that the it's almost
like Hollywood and the music industry
are you are fighting it when the these
songs come out Surfer the one on uh
Bethany Hamilton that they they all tend
to do well Passion of the Christ they do
well and yet Hollywood goes well instead
let's make another one that has to do
with you know uh a bunch of smut and
things like that and yet here's a song
like this no marketing no agent no
nothing bust to the top of the charts
you talk about your experience people
want good content good music they they
almost are like well how do we then Jam
them back with some more crap yeah it's
it is what I find foreign
if you're always eating sugar you're
always gonna need a dentist right
because you have cavities like they do
this because the music isn't fulfilling
to your soul and so therefore you're
trying to try new things and go watch
more TV and more movies you're looking
for that connection I think this
solidify is what I've been saying for
probably about 15 years we are the media
when they say the media that's us this
is he's got four songs in the iTunes top
ten yeah go buy them all she's got rich
men north of Richmond is number one
ain't got a dollar number three
seven I've got to get sober and eight I
wanna go home can we get away with
playing any of that right now no I will
I don't have anything I've only heard
this his number one I haven't heard but
they get more support and that's what
some people in the chat like a couple
days ago they get more sport he gets
more sport if you go to his actual
Channel and you go and watch his video
you go and buy the actual thing if you
want to support him the best thing you
can do is look it up yourself and go and
buy it because it just that just shows
the algorithm more people came there
naturally so I'm just just so unclear is
are you saying don't go to iTunes no no
iTunes and buy it okay spend that dollar
spend that one dollar because that one
dollar is equal to listening to the song
150 times exactly and if all 40 000
people who are watching right now buy
that song for one dollar it's going to
help him blast off but more importantly
if all 40 000 people who are watching
tell all their friends and family who
like the song to buy it hey look he's
got he's got 19 million views on YouTube
let's say that everyone listened to the
song Twice let's just say he's got nine
million let's just put it down let's
let's say that three million unique
listeners imagine if they each bought
that song for one dollar Not only would
this dude be a millionaire because he'd
take home like two point something
million then taxes come in he'd take
home about a million something but he
would be I think that would put him
double Platinum yeah these are the
double Platinum debut for this song and
that's if people just go and search a
song go look like I just like it seems
better to like give him the platform for
on our Channel but that's the best way
to help it I want this guy to be a
millionaire and to be successful and I
want I want young people to look at him
and his message and be like that's your
path to success I don't want them to
look at wet ass and be like that's
how you're going to be famous a famous
musician I want them to look at Oliver
Anthony and be like that's your path to
me being a musician being real being
genuine and like honor integrity real
issues and I just want the massive
multinational entertainment industry in
industrial complex to fail so like
please just buy this sound of Freedom
does a uh a thing where you can pay it
forward where you buy the tickets and
other people get them for free so I
think a lot of people that watch YouTube
can't do this I can't do it you cannot
deal with music says I was going to ask
is there a system where we can pay it
forward for artists there are I put a
thousand bucks into this guy so a
thousand people could have it there they
they don't allow that but we should
start doing it even if it doesn't count
towards the views well because people
because then Taylor Swift will go in and
be like put 100 million dollars into
give this song for free and then I'm
number one for 10 weeks but if you if it
didn't count towards the views if it
just let people hear it I mean they can
hear it on YouTube anyway yeah that's
why I'm saying everybody who's already
listening to the song and likes it you
got to buy it yeah definitely you man I
wish all 40 000 people listening right
now just went and bought it
is there a way that we can see
again this is not my world here can we
see where it is right now I'd love to
see you can't see it real time see what
or what is I would love to know real
time because Tina's point oh he knows
yeah so he's got access to the back end
where he can probably see streams coming
in and not necessarily sales there are
some apis that I can I can
yeah if if his um if he's got anybody
with access to I think it's called
illuminate then they can see in real
time but it might take a day to update
or something like you have his number
Chris's number no Chris
hit me up I'm sure he's got John Rich
helping him oh good John get us in touch
man they're good he lives close by dude
I know he's like two and a half hours so
we're gonna rock so hard with the
vehicle you know what hold on let's just
go let's roll right now let's get in the
car right now just drive to Farmville
we'll start yelling Chris where are you
at Farmville
uh no well there's the reason I just not
that I am but there was decided that was
the site of the vice presidential debate
in 2015. oh ah yeah it's not like you
were like hey yeah
you're just driving through no it's a
beautiful beautiful place in Virginia
though yeah yeah I remember the video
game that's about it is that what was it
based on the city no did he put
FarmVille on the map yeah Farm film
he's got uh in the country he's got a
bunch he's got what he's got one two
three four he's got five songs in the
top country charts and four songs in the
iTunes top I like Chris Anthony I think
that's a better name than Oliver Anthony
that's too late brother
keep calling him Chris and let the
people be damned no offense be confused
I should say if you don't understand who
I'm talking about but it's Chris Anthony
like don't put him through that don't
change his name but I mean maybe he did
it to himself because he loves his
grandfather right like I mean shout out
to Oliver yeah Ollie Anthony yeah big
Granddad making magic he also had a
ginger beard like just a great genetic
Trace it's gonna be Ian's trivia
question Chris Anthony what is the real
name
yeah Chris Anthony's that sounds like
that that a wizard that magician what's
his name
yeah he's still doing his thing in Vegas
I think oh no way dude talk about music
changing the freaking world exactly
totally so cool winning the cultural
battles is how you win everything
because again there's gonna be some 15
year old kid he's gonna hear about this
the number one song 19 million views in
a week and he's gonna say I want that I
want people I want to make the work that
everyone loves and respects and he's
gonna be looking at a guy who's talking
about the working class being screwed
over and when you listen to musicians
when you're 9 and 12 years old and you
listen to a musician over and over and
over and over and you're writing it in
you become like that later in life if
you want to become a musician that's
part of you like Eddie Vedder was that
for me I would 12 years old in my
bedroom over and over Pearl Jam Non-Stop
and now that just comes out of me like
that that growl you know it's part of
how I how I communicate and so this
guy's doing it for Oliver's doing that
for kids right now can I ask do you guys
know and I was late to the not I saw the
video when it when everyone else kind of
when it but how what was the what was
the the wick like the that Lit him I
don't know I woke up one more I know all
of a sudden I was talking about I saw it
on Twitter
yeah it didn't have that much views at
all but I saw one Gino and a bunch of
these other guys there's some connective
tissue to a bunch of these guys some
some guy who saw it first yeah and and
they were tweeting out that's the guy
and he but and then once that takes like
the algorithm takes it and then it
starts you know putting in for people
that it thinks you'll probably like this
I think for the most I think this was a
natural viral phenomenon people on the
right hearing the song and posting it in
replies and sharing it with you know
Jack besobic said you know would be a
shame if this song went viral and then
yeah people start clicking retweeting it
Jack said don't even remember last time
a new song hit me like this I mean I
hear you jack actually after I read
Jack's tweet is when I listened to it
and I got the Goosebumps because I I I
heard it through Jack's ears this is
wild I wonder if he was the first one to
put on the map August 11th but so so so
this it's all part of the bigger picture
with the failures of Bud Light the
failures of Target the successive sound
of Freedom it is people saying we're not
gonna buy your weird Sodom and Gamora
garbage anymore and we're gonna focus on
things that actually matter to us yeah
that is the bicot that is the boycott
and if that keeps up
in a few years we're not going to be
we're not going to be complaining about
Target anymore you know why Target's
going to have a cardboard cut out of
Oliver Anthony they're going to get rid
of all their weird child you know LGBT
stuff because it doesn't make money and
it freaks people out and these big
corporations are gonna what they're
gonna do is they're gonna start
shoveling all that stuff into the into
the back under the rug and be like no no
we were never about that we we like what
you like come come give us your money
yes what is popular what is popular
absolutely and you know what I do of
course I still I still despise the faces
Corporation but we want Target to
replace their pride section with the you
know yeah Appalachian music collection
you want them to be chasing your values
that would be an incredible win and be
nice to see this happen yeah they turned
around making sure like the the like the
industries are actually chasing what
Everyone likes not the industry telling
everyone what they like and then selling
them what the industry tells them you
should like this it's people saying I
actually like this and then force and
those companies to catch them but okay
we'll say this then because you like it
you know yo you said pride and I was
like I mean this guy's got American
Pride he's singing about the threads of
the United States it's funny that uh try
that in a small town it's currently
number six
oh wow they're so salty about all of
this country music and fast car Luke
Combs got in trouble for singing it even
though Tracy Chapman was like no it's
fine if he covers it and they're like no
a white man cannot sing this song and
it's still there fast car yeah who
covered it Luke Combs who's like a
country singer dude what a great song Oh
Tracy Chapman's amazing yeah is this the
top or is this country this is top wow
all songs
it's impressive yeah what's John rich is
working with Oliver right now Chris John
that's what I heard that's so good I
texted John yeah he is he has been
helping him out he offered to um uh put
them on a label or whatever like help
the public so yeah I got goosebumps
again man uh John Rich we went to his
place he's got a magnificent
headquarters it's like a multi-storied
uh giant guitar pool on like the fifth
door floor no he literally his pool is a
guitar oh that's right yeah guitar you
can see it from the roof yeah did you go
to the the music stage and Sound Stage
on the fourth floor or whatever and it's
got a few stories yeah it's a mess we
have photos over there we got to jam on
his stage but the best part about it is
that when he tells you the zoning story
uh and I can't remember all the
particulars of it because but he was
they were like well you can't do this
with your house right because of where
lies because we say so because in
Nashville proper so he's like well then
what I will do is I will carve this I
mean like it's it's a master of like his
I love talking to him about his stories
because if you ever know the story about
how John Rich got redneck Riviera have
you ever heard that so I'll just I'll
give you the cliff note version so he
goes to trademark and his lawyer comes
back and says yeah in the Trademark
Office says you can't trademark a
geographic location and so sorry we
can't we can't uh we can't do it and
John Rich goes oh okay where is it
and they said what do you mean he goes
well you said it's a geographical
location so where's the redneck Riviera
and they go uh he goes just tell me and
they go oh it's uh it's on the panhandle
of Florida he goes oh because I'm also
seeing that it's in a place in Delaware
off the coast of you know such and such
in Texas and he goes so there's like 62
places that claim to be the redneck
Riviera and he's like so which
geographic Place am I trademarking
and after a fight back and forth with
with all of these lawyers in the patent
and trademark office finally they were
like you win dude so he owns the patent
to Redneck Riviera because of the
trademark because it the trademark to it
because initially the government the
lawyers are like no unfortunately and
he's like no I'm not gonna take no for
an answer
and he fight and fight and fight and now
he's got redneck Riviera liquor and and
uh his barbecue barbecue sauce low-key
genius that is brilliant he's like so
humble when I met him yeah I met him and
I'd like I just looked over and I was
like oh just a guy sitting there I
didn't even know if he was gonna be a
guest I didn't know who he was and then
I started talking to him I'm like okay
this guy's legit and then I got to know
more and then I realized like his
business Acumen and like but he's so
humble yeah I wouldn't know like talking
to him that he's this like genius
businessman it is it is funny being in
his like what was it like his third
floor or whatever which is a music his
house the music venue and bar and then
I'm like oh what are all these and he's
like oh those are all my my chart
topping songs and there's like this row
going across the wall I'm like holy he's
got the original lyrics to all of these
songs that he wrote A Cowboy yes yeah
and other other artists too that he's
followed throughout the years he's got
like their original lyrics that they
scrawled on like on like I don't know
his napkins paper yeah you're right the
beauty is he is an unbelievably
brilliant businessman
I love before we go to super chats it
was an honor to to be invited to John's
house to hang out with him he's a good
dude glad to have him on the show really
excited for the stuff he's working on
really excited for Oliver Anthony let's
read super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
and head over to timcast.com click join
us become a member so that you can watch
the members only uncensored show
and uh we will take calls from you the
members and uh you can actually talk to
us and our guest all right let's go
blave Kaiser says there will be no
coffee purchases until we get Sheamus's
sweet potato pie swirl and vociferon
Herald of the winter blend
uh we are working right now on the
Sheamus blend actually yes yeah we've
got a couple we have re-rise with
Roberto Jr because as much as we love
and miss Roberto Jr uh we are not
without humor so we have a special
limited edition limited edition
Halloween blend that we're gonna be
putting together
we're only going to do 500 bags of it
and we're hoping that we can number the
bags I'm not sure that we can we're
reaching out to the company who makes
the bags because they have to be hand
labeled and then uh if we can it'll be
cool you'll get like bag one of 500. can
we do 666 bags or is that too we might
not be able to because of the way they
they do bag printing but we can try
that'd be nice and it's hot it's for
Halloween so so Sheamus Sheamus will
come here and throw holy water on all of
you Irish coffee no no that it's too
generic yeah it didn't really work we
tried we we did we got samples and we
tried to put together some kind of it
didn't really work so we got to figure
out something that works for Sheamus you
know I think like a more earthy uh dark
roast so that we equate to potatoes I
like the sweet potato blend like I mean
I don't know how it kind of sounds gross
but maybe it would be earthy earthy
Ireland you just put Sheamus's face on
the bag we have we have yeah little
cartoon sheamuses so and then uh there's
a couple other we were going to do I
think we're gonna do we want to do an
Alex Stein one
yeah yep Prime Time grind oh yeah well
that'd be great that was so funny just
like extra caffeine in that one yeah
yeah we could do we could yeah that's
actually a really good idea Prime Time
Stein caffeine 99 yeah I love that all
right here we go waffle sense it says
okay okay new plan Trump goes to prison
we elect the vague the vague makes Trump
VP the vague wins and then Vivek resigns
and becomes Trump VP checkmate I don't
think Vivek would resign if he got
elected president yeah they would be
able to do something that would be fun
but
he said
Raymond Jason says better plan Trump
raises an army of anti-fascists and they
take over the White House and call it
what White House antifa territory Trump
Reigns his King haha I guess the funny
thing is if antifa stormed the White
House nothing would happen yeah the FBI
would be like well that's fine totally
okay
they're peacefully uh occupying the
White House we love it when they do this
yeah don't mind those fires
all right we'll grab some more Super
Chips
now servusen says everybody needs to go
out and vote in 2024. even if you think
it doesn't matter if you can't take a
few hours to cast a ballot then you
might as well shut up sit down and wait
for the downfall of the U.S here's the
other thing y'all should do right now is
go to iTunes and buy Richmond north of
Richmond buy it yeah what do you think
if you can't if you can't because the
dollar really stresses you out I get it
man you know don't do that some people
really are trying to make every every
penny go as far as possible especially
with costs but if you have the dollar
you buy that song man and if you got the
ears give it a listen make make Oliver
Anthony a millionaire and make him
double platinum and make all of these
industry celebrities beg to be a part of
something wholesome and good Force the
culture to abandon the creepy woke
garbage and embrace the wholesome and
the good that super chatter mentioned
voting like making voting more
challenging is that what they were
saying they're just saying to make sure
you go out yeah what it made me think of
is something Vivek Rama Swami's been
talking about which is uh that we could
increase like the the bar to be able to
vote that anyone that's 18 years old
would have to pass a Civics test just
like someone that wanted to get
citizenship in order to gain the right
to vote at 18 what do you do you know I
don't I I mean look this is I think at
some point uh
I I get his point but this is a
breakdown like we've got to start
putting history back in classrooms I
mean there's having a test and again
who's going to write the test the same
numbnuts that are that are running
everything right now I don't trust I
don't trust the government to put a test
together have you ever looked at the
citizenship test it's 100 questions that
they give you you have to get 10 right
and you're gonna I mean so I get his
point but I'm not trusting a bunch of
bureaucrats to put a test together
because I know who's not going to pass
it well I like when we we talked he said
how about when you sign up for the
Selective Service you get your voter ID
card so you can choose to sign up for
not men and women both
if you want to vote you sign up that's
it no guarantee you get drafted but in
order to vote you have to
I think there is an element of public
service that I don't mind whereas I I
think you go that route and you'd be
surprised Democrats lose all their
voters yeah but yeah I agree and that
Massive Resistance I don't I like I said
I'm I'm a fan of of having to serve the
country
um but I just can't I mean enough of
these guys control enough levers that
they're never going to let anything go
through yeah I agree
I'm not your guy friend says Alex Stein
99 was hysterical hysterical calling out
far right Tom Poole as he once again
trolled the Plano Texas Town Council did
you guys see that no oh wait I think
they have blue hair yeah yeah yeah did
he mention me or the show so no no I
just heard him screaming until they shut
his camera off that's what I saw why
just shut me down he's still recording
it it's awesome ray Jacob says Hannah
Giles the CEO Veritas is actually an
accomplished black belt at my Jujitsu
School in Miami whether you like her or
not she is someone that you don't want
to pick a fight with on the street she
is very very good
you know I hear that but
I don't know what that has to do with
firing people and not fundraising and
you know like betraying staff or
whatever so I'm you know yeah like you
know did Mark Zuckerberg's a blue belt
yeah I don't know how that's relevant to
me I guess we're never gonna fight yeah
I'm not going to be like Mark before we
have this debate you know we're going to
do a sanctioned match
yeah don't go out and fight her okay I
think I think it is fair to say this
because I'm I am a humble person I think
it is fair to say that Mark Zuckerberg
could beat up everybody in this room
yeah probably oh uh yeah Alex Stein did
say Tim Poole he was like you guys are
censoring people far right activists
like Tim Poole I mean he said something
like that it was really funny
he said Tim I remember listening to any
I remember he mentioned you so a lot of
people would want to be like big and
tough and be like I could take
Zuckerberg I'm like maybe because he's
not that big of a guy like I guess Elon
Musk said with my height and weight
Advantage I'm probably gonna win even
with training and that's a fair point
but uh I think it's fair to say like I'm
not I'm never gonna pretend that I can
take someone in a fight who's literally
training in Jujitsu or something like
that I will just defer to they probably
beat me up I'll try I mean maybe maybe I
could do it at this point I think either
is trolling I don't think he has any
intention no Zuckerberg's the one who
pulled out yeah but that's because like
oh yeah it wasn't following through
that's true Elon I I don't believe that
for a second
it's because Mark Zuckerberg was like
this should be going through UFC or or
one and Elon was like we should do it in
Italy at the Coliseum and Mark
Zuckerberg was like that's not a serious
match yep I feel like the Coliseum is a
pretty serious Place elon's idea was a
more goofy thing and Zuckerberg's like
no I want a UFC title yeah he said it
was going to look purely Roman like old
Roman all the all the modern stuff would
not be in the frame so it just looked
like an old you know Coliseum battle I
feel like Mark Zuckerberg's just trying
to get away from the fact that everyone
thinks he's kind of a robot I think Mark
is like I would hurt that guy and I
don't want to hurt his neck I don't want
to break his arm and he's old and I
don't want to do that to him they could
have made the fight in like six months
and then if Elon had just done all that
his entire the entire time and trained
then it would have been it's you know so
you think if if
Mark had called his bluff when Elon said
come over to my house or I'll come over
to your house do you really think that
uh you think it would have gone through
right then and there yeah if he said
fine come on over Elon would have shown
up
did practice with Lex Friedman and just
practice his practice practice
yes he is he is yes Lex rolls yeah sorry
I don't really keep up with Lex Friedman
you should yeah he's a martial artist
right that's so awesome but Elon said he
wanted to have a practice about with
with Mark it sounds like Elon is more
having a silly fun time and he wanted to
goof off and Zuckerberg wants a serious
UFC match and Lex is a brown belt for
yeah oh okay yeah Lex I've watched some
videos he knows what he's doing yeah he
said it was the toughest Lexus no
question would beat up everybody in this
room yeah but would you beat up Mark
Zuckerberg that's the question
absolutely yeah if he's a blue belt
every soccer wears Blue Bell he's a
brown boat yes yeah it's it's like I
don't know how much I care about the
idea that someone accredited you with a
colored belt it's just fair to say that
Friedman's got way more experience
fighting yeah it's just time spent doing
it you know yeah
laughs
I love Lex so much let's see CH Cowboys
as I believe if Trump goes to prison
that is the clearest sign we're dealing
with Communists let me let me just pause
right there and be like we we have
they're holding up giant red flags
literally they are holding up giant red
communist Flags you know he's I fear
there can't be peaceful resolution if
we're dealing with a Marxist Insurgency
yeah
I think it's funny when it's like when
you when you see an antifa rally the the
the biggest red flag you're dealing with
Communists is that they're holding up a
large red kind of a large communist flag
oh
man what is this
cap says son uh saw an article on my
phone today that said the posting
Georgia indictments early wasn't an
accident but a practice run
these people are insane yeah yeah
shred count says what are your thoughts
on Mike lindell's big plan revealed
today I don't know what was it did
anyone see it oh that's what he was
talking about on our on our yeah on the
loudest culture war of all time
uh he I I didn't watch it I'll go back
and check it out but he did mention that
he wanted to go on the show on the 18th
a tomorrow to come and discuss what he
is going to talk about last night
I don't either that was Matt Brainerd
and Mike Lindell it was a very loud
culture I highly recommend everyone
watch it but oh tomorrow's going to be
wild tomorrow we have Laura Loomer uh
Bill Mitchell and Kyle Becker yeah and
uh and uh interesting and we're going to
have a we're going spirited attempt to
have a conversation about conversation
cool I think it'll be cool I think it'll
be it'll be an interesting conversation
that I think a lot of people want to
hear uh it just might be very lively
that's how I now describe
ready to go yeah yeah coffee early
because it goes live at what 9 A.M 10
a.m live tomorrow morning at youtube.com
cast and I imagine it's going to be
Laura spitten hard facts very very very
very very fast yes yeah yeah okay so
don't let her Gish Gallop you gotta hold
control we'll see I I I honestly think
the issue is I'm I'm not going to sit
here and be like oh Ron detention is
donors they said or otherwise but I
think talking about the campaign and you
know policy it's like there's Fair
criticisms
we'll see how it goes we'll see how it
goes I think it'll be a good time the
thing that I find interesting and again
there's this sort of existential debate
about who's better at work I try to I
keep looking at things very analytically
and which I said earlier in the show I
if he doesn't win Iowa it doesn't matter
Trump's gonna it's over and this is all
about accumulating the requisite number
of delegates about 1400 delegates you
you don't get delegates by coming if you
don't
beat the guy right and at the end of the
day this good bad it's it's it doesn't
it's an existential debate because at
the end of the day right now Trump's
organization in these early States is
such that unless you show he can be beat
he's going to steamroll collect the
requisite number of delegates and it's
over by super Tuesday so
you can tell me that Ron DeSantis has
the magic formula to do everything in
the world if he can't actually take down
Trump in Iowa because he's not really
competing as much in New Hampshire then
it's it doesn't matter right and that's
that's what I keep coming back to tell
me how he can win
all right Blake says Tim the Republican
party is the party of the working class
the working class is mostly Normie folk
Sean is right people won't react to
Biden ballot
Hutchinson says Kevin McCarthy with a
need for only one Challenger to
challenge his speaker position after
screwing Us in the debt ceiling and the
last budget fight announced that he
would do another continuing resolution
on the next budget Bill and no one
challenge I remember talking about Gates
about the the debt ceiling and how they
keep raising it my whole life they've
just raised the Dead Sea I'm like what
is it is this a joke like they say it's
a ceiling that they continue to raise
there's no ceiling it and and Matt was
just looking at me like smiling because
he knew how ridiculous it is they all
know how do you what do we do I mean
it's just there is no I mean I guess you
could say it's a temporary ceiling
that's going to be put beyond that what
would have infuriates me is that when
you have the fight they say you can't
fight because if we don't do this is
what's gonna happen I get that right
there's these Economic Consequences
which are debatable but the point is
that every time that we get there they
go if we do this all these bad things
are gonna happen so let's wait till
after let's raise it
and then they it's no one ever does
anything it's literally like saying you
know you got to lose weight but let's
just go to the buffet one more time
and then no one actually ever does any I
just don't get the debate we we there
are so many
low-hanging fruits that could be dealt
with and these guys wait until the last
minute and they're going to do it again
we're heading towards September there's
I think Congress is testing 12 days and
they're gonna go we have to do a CR
because the government's going to run
out of money well where were you the 11
last months we we do this whether it's a
debt ceiling or the or the continuing
resolutions at the end of the year every
time and then the guys we're running out
of time we've got to do this
yeah I found out that we can make
hydrogen fuel real cheap now we can
actually get paid to make hydrogen
because you get the byproduct of
graphene but carbon and they can turn
into graphene and sell the graphene for
four dollars and fifty cents for every
kilogram of carbon or of hydrogen that
they produce so like we basically
figured out how to make free hydrogen
how to get paid for making hydrogen why
is that immediately implemented now in
the government why is that an
immediately the the number one move for
the United States government because
that will make that's very specific yeah
hydrogen maybe the energy committee
should be asked that question but also
can I you're on the revenue side which I
am a fan of as well but why are we
Republicans the the Constitution says
that the house representatives were all
funding shall start there's so many low
hanging for why are we funding PBS and
NPR that that should be like I mean and
that's that's a minuscule amount but the
illustrative stuff show that you
actually care I just don't get these
easy ones those are the layups everybody
would say great you can get if
again I just wanna I wanna read this one
here this is from uh what does it say J
train M come to Moyock North Carolina
did I pronounce it Oliver is playing
this Saturday at Eagle Creek Golf Course
nice so you heard it here everybody go
go oh God can you imagine being the
manager at Eagle Creek golf course
you're getting phone calls right now get
your tickets yeah he put out a tweet
that was like I'll be at this farmer's
market on August 15th it's so fun yeah I
think it was crazy he was like I'll stay
until 2AM and shake hands like I'm
thinking that poor farmer's market
organizer must be like but what about
the parking Bender the offender says Tim
do you think the U.S will be in an
active Civil War and World War III if it
escalates to that in the same time
period no
because if the U.S does destabilize to
the point of Civil War we won't be
involved in World War Three we'll be
involved in a civil war and there will
there will be no world war three that's
what happened with the Bolshevik
Revolution is they went internal split
off and they basically weren't involved
in World War one yeah yeah they were and
then the the revolution then the
revolution began and then they pulled
out yeah yeah
it'll be interesting times
Cosmic surgeon says None watched Mike
Lindell today no ballot harvesting I
didn't I didn't watch Mike Lindell is
that what it was about I mean he was a
yeah he said when he was here to debate
that he was against ballast
he was saying that we needed to uh stick
to the rules that if you uh if you're
about harvesting from I don't want to
paraphrase this argument too much but if
you're about harvesting you're doing
something that we shouldn't support
anyways everyone should show up on
Election Day and have paper ballots and
vote in person uh and the conversation
was interesting because it's you know a
question of like well these are the
rules we have should we let the other
party use the system to their advantage
or should we say you don't believe in
these things so we should try and resist
them I I don't disagree with them but
the ship has sailed this is the point
you were talking about earlier guys
guess what I I think ballot harvesting
is ridiculous in fact it was illegal in
a lot of states and yet the Dems
weaponized it the ship has sailed either
we keep complaining about it or or we
find out a way to undo it but you can't
we're literally going to let them get
away with this uh and win more and more
and more so I I'm with Mike in principle
but either change the lawn or or get on
board Warren Heist says I just watched
that Arizona is going for the fifth
indictment that's right yeah but I think
what I heard about Arizona is they're
going after the state level stuff we'll
see if they go after Trump I could be
wrong maybe they are
business phone says Ian watched the
whole clip the code would change the
vote count and then eat itself so it
couldn't be detected if the source code
was examined in person hand counted
destructible paper ballots like we used
to I'm sorry wait he said that the code
would the guy who said he hacked the
voting machine said the code he put on
it would change the votes and then
self-destruct no he didn't no he hasn't
who no he said that you wouldn't know
that it changed the votes unless you had
access to the code and you don't have
access to the code that's what the guy
said this person says if you watch the
whole I'll rewatch it again maybe you're
watching a shorter version of it okay
thanks
what do we have here Google Simon Says
North Brazil former president bolsonaro
was sentenced to eight years of
Eligibility by the superior electoral
court for saying that the voting
machines were unreliable eight years of
Eligibility what does that mean probably
ineligibility ineligibility I imagine so
mookie says got the Appalachian nights
coffee smoothest cough you've ever had
will buy again it's it's amazing look
I'll be completely honest with my
assessment on the coffee
Roberto Roger Roberto Jr 10 out of 10.
it's my favorite and then I have
Appalachian nights and I'm like oh man
10 out of 10. this one's my favorite
pumpkin spice is mine it's good it's
good not my favorite uh but it's good
and um stand your grounds is so rise of
the Proto Junior and Appalachian Knights
are battling for my top position because
one's light one's dark but man they're
both good and then stand your grounds is
like right there in the middle
French roast to me is a c c plus it's
good it's a good cup of coffee it's
better than like you know gas station
coffee or something like that so I enjoy
it but I gotta tell you the Appalachian
nights
wow and I have yet to try the decaf ones
though we did the samples of them a long
time ago I'll put it that way like I've
tried them all but I need to have a cup
of coffee now that they're here packaged
and cracked open because getting sample
packages is different I tasted the
Sleepy Joe it's a little sweet I was
surprisingly and like uh it's like
bitter it's like Bittersweet I don't
know I didn't see the I didn't see the
beans and then it doesn't have much of
an aftertaste it's very clean it's
awesome
let's grab some more
Dylan Gilman says please provide a link
to sign up for cast Brew franchising
newsletter we don't have one we have
literally done nothing towards the
concept of franchising castbrew but I
want to because I would love it if there
were a thousand locations in five years
and it was just a decentralized network
that's what it's all about everybody
runs their own locations but people know
that you can hang out there what I'm
really excited for with it is something
we're talking about doing called
Saturday morning cartoons where parents
bring their kids in it's like 7 A.M we
have pancakes sausage eggs like buffet
style and then the kids play and hang
out the TVs are on with approved you
know Saturday morning cartoons and then
you hang out till whenever you feel like
it maybe the event ends at noon or
whatever but when I grew up we had
Saturday morning cartoons and now you
don't have any of that anymore so this
is a kind of like a secular Community
Building thing where a lot of people who
don't go to church they come to this and
they hang out it gives some kind of
facsimile of it I don't think it's a
perfect exchange but people meeting
their neighbors kids Growing Up near
each other and becoming friends I think
is a really really important thing would
you would you and I'm just throwing this
out there on brainstorm farming would
you be willing to consider the new Sean
Spicer show going on like in the
afternoon absolutely okay that's the
plan that's okay the plan is that we
have these TVs and when there'll be some
woman on our way to work and she'll be
like I need to grab a cup of coffee and
then she'll look on her phone she'll be
like okay you know Casper coffee she
walks in she walks through the counter
and she goes I'll take the dark roast
and I'll leave room for cream and
they're like you got it and while
they're pouring it she's like getting
her money out she looks up and there's a
TV and there's Stephen Crowder talking
about something or there's Viva fry or
there's Sean Spicer and then she's just
sitting there they go here's your coffee
man she goes oh oh thank you and she
pays and then she's holding the coffee
and she's looking and she steps a little
bit she goes huh she walks out she goes
to work and then someone's like hey
Janet how's it going like how are you
it's like no no what's going on like you
know I just heard about that thing the
Biden thing did you see that where he
was telling the pros to fire the guy and
I'll give you the money or whatever did
you hear about that it's on the news or
something that's what I that's the goal
you know it'll be cool as if it was the
monitors were all Bluetooth and you
could put it'd be nice if the volume's
on but like sometimes I don't want to
listen to TV when I'm drinking I just
want to chill so there's an area like oh
cool the idea is there's like an area
with the TV and so if you're standing
away from it you'll be able to hear it
but you can sit down in front of it and
hear it a lot of places have it kind of
like this there's the TVs on and you can
sit down by it and you'll hear it walk
away from it you don't yo we should get
um pancake maker for the kids so they
can make their own pancakes oh no no no
they have the automatic ones you ever
see yeah yeah you press the hotels they
have yeah press the button and it's you
watch the Residence Inn those are great
yeah and then it Cooks them on both
sides at the same time that's what we
got hungry now get a good batter
pancakes
okay let's grab another Super Chat
Matthew Schneider says literally bought
that song 10 seconds before you said buy
it LOL great just got it you got it but
you got to tell your friends and family
to buy it too so if you know anybody who
was like oh yeah I love that song Or you
know somebody who's listening to it or
you know someone you've shared with
already you got to be like hey guys buy
that on iTunes right now we want this
guy to be a rock star we want rock stars
to be synonymous with being a good
person who's talk who's singing about
American values and fighting for the
working class and not about wet ass
yep yeah I mean like we got we got
we got to work for that okay yeah you
got to spend that dollar
realign realign the culture and and win
the culture War
Joseph says men six feet in the ground
show respect it's rough yeah man I
watched a video where he was playing
live and I could see people singing
along to it nodding along and you could
see like these guys knew exactly what he
was saying amazing
people are saying it's an Anthem wow
whoa what do you got here we got some
more super jets Joshua Lively says this
is my first real super chat to you guys
but I thought I should tell you my
family and I just saw a string of 20 to
30 green lights flying in the sky over
the house never saw anything like this
have video and photo to send as well do
you wanna you wanna get you want to
watch that yeah is it yes tweeted at you
right yes tweeted at Ian Crossland
Russell liberty lockdown
pod
it's a 100 000 followers um lasers raise
tiny dinosaurs says rip Roberto Jr I
recently got six chicks one of them
turned out to be a rooster so I had to
find him a new home his adoptive parents
now want to find him a new home because
he's so aggressive frowny-face that's
the bummer about Roberto Jr he was super
chill Roberto is Roberto's aggressive
you know he's he's he was the king and
it's because he was born in a chicken
farm and all the boys got cold but him
because I thought it was a girl and then
uh he got to grow up Roberto Jr was
raised by us so he was super calm and
relaxed around people
and then he had a heart attack and died
suddenly yep just abruptly and I looked
it up and it's like sometimes roosters
have heart attacks and I was like damn
and then his sister died shortly after
that yeah unrelated it's lots of tragedy
around here with the chickens it's hard
chickens die a lot I think they can see
you know birds can see the
electromagnetic field they used to think
it was like I think it's iron in their
beak or a chemical in their beak that
they could navigate with but now they
believe they can actually see it's a
protein in their eye or something and
they can actually see the Earth's
magnetic field that's how they all fly
in Synergy that murmuration where you
see these big flocks all coming together
and moving it you can actually see it I
wonder if they could see it and if they
were connected to it and that's why a
sister felt such pain that she she flew
away shortly after that's crazy it was
the it was three three babies that
hatched the first eggs that we hatched
and they were a weak batch we knew it
you know that like the chickens we got
were young they had their eggs we we
hatched them now they got tons of babies
Roberto's got oh man Roberto's got like
30 kids and like 30 grandkids did you
decide uh who's gonna be his Heir not
yet they've got a little bit older but
Roberto Roberto III Roberto Jr's son
Roberto Jr the second
Roberto Jr Jr yeah
we were trying to figure out figure out
a name for Roberto Jr and then I was
just like he's he's Junior you know he's
like Roberto's son and then they've they
fought after a little while roosters
don't fight the way people think they
fight if we like we have little Luke in
the in the chicken City right now with
Roberto they mind their they stay away
from each other and they just mind each
other they mind their own business and
then they have their their girls or
whatever but you can have a bunch of
different roosters depending on how many
hens you have people think they put two
roosters together they just start going
at each other they don't know but uh
sometimes they do because they're like
dudes you know sometimes dudes fight is
what it is all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member because
the members only uncensored show is
starting in just a few minutes and you
don't want to miss it it's going to be
good fun we got a lot of stuff to talk
about you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast Sean do you want to shout
anything out yeah new show starts on
Monday please follow me Sean M Spicer on
YouTube you can go to rumble Sean
spicershow.com but the same thing we've
been talking about please I appreciate
your support uh want to build up a
bigger subscriber base and and uh and be
part happy be part of that Community as
we navigate this upcoming election give
you the behind the scenes take as to
what's happening and why and hopefully
how we can use the rules to win again
Sean spicershow.com Sean M Spicer on
YouTube thank you run on that's awesome
uh I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
you can see the work from all of our
journalists and I want to say a special
thank you to Chris Carr our executive
editor because I have tons of typos he
puts up with it if you want to follow me
personally you can follow me on Twitter
at Hannah Claire or at HC brimo and on
Instagram at handclare.b thank you so
much Ian Crossland hit me up on X at Ian
cross and Sean Spicer at on X at Sean
Spicer what time does your show go up on
Monday six o'clock Eastern Eastern
Standard 16 p.m eastern time so you
finish that then you can have a cup of
Tim Tim cast Brew then Jump Right In I
mean this we timed it it was all the
flavor yeah and uh also I'm in a race
with Clint Russell liberty lockdown pod
on X and we are both heading towards a
hundred thousand followers you must
follow me and Clint Russell on X and
whichever one I see I'm like Vivek man I
only want a fair contest here uh so I
want to see who's going to win who's
going to get to 100 000 first it's gonna
be mere Clint cast your vote follow like
subscribe and I'll see you later
uh I am definitely gonna follow Ian but
I follow both you guys alrighty so it's
whatever
um yeah I'm serge.com I hope you guys uh
have a wonderful evening or if you if
you are a member please join us a number
show uh it'll be nice to hear you guys
say stuff uh what else can I say uh I
guess shout out to the people of Maui
right now anyways cheers all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out